so it's one of those days where elon
musk posts a poop emoji
at the ceo of twitter and you know
things are going good uh but hey good
for him for for making things a bit more
interesting i suppose but the story is
the ceo of twitter basically said we
can't do an external audit of twitter's
spam bots because you need internal data
therefore elon musk's audit of bots
won't be he's basically saying his audit
won't work
they're also apparently accusing elon of
violating his non-non-disclosure
agreement by revealing that twitter only
surveyed 100 accounts
to figure out how many bots they had on
the platform
which is remarkably low but i also think
isn't the full picture what i imagine
they did is it's a hundred
fifty times so they look at a hundred
they look at 100 they look at 100. but
now they're accusing me of violining as
nda elon apparently is is
it's being reported trying to negotiate
lower terms like a lower lower price
personally i think elon may have
discovered fraud because we know that
twitter has misrepresented their numbers
on two different occasions and two
different reports and we had the crazy
swing in user accounts uh the week
before they announced their bot numbers
so we'll talk about all that we got a
bunch of other stories um we're going to
get into and some of them are going to
be well i'll just i'll just say this one
we have i'm trending on twitter because
i made a tweet about abortion
because i had a conversation with a
friend in new york about abortion and he
didn't know what was in the law and so i
tweeted something that was like
incendiary and everybody got mad so
we'll talk about that plus we got to
talk about what happened in buffalo
because uh well for one it's a tragedy
it's horrifying and we should we should
definitely be talking about uh the
breaking news but i also want to talk
about um
there's been other mass shootings too we
got starbucks they're going to be paying
for
abortion and gender change surgeries for
uh their staffers so a lot going on
today and i'm sure a whole lot more and
joining us to discuss all of this is
matt bender hello everybody pleasure to
be here looking forward to talking
absolutely matt who are you who am i
well for a long time people probably
still because i'm on there every week
i'm on the majority report with sam
cedar i know you're a big fan tim
um also i have a show called doomed with
matt bender that covers the far right
white supremacists conspiracy theories
like q anon and i have a show about
crypto that takes it on from a leftist
perspective called scam economy
we are gonna have so many disagreements
it's gonna be great it's gonna be fun so
we'll definitely talk about matt thanks
for coming no problem we have a we have
a long history um and i don't think you
realize because you've previously spoken
about your your long history with the
majority report with sam cedar wow um
because one thing i mean you said it was
the first media show to mention that's a
pretty big deal i mean you don't forget
that that's right um sam was your first
whether you like it or not um yeah he
said uh
what did he say did he he said i was
okay i think right he said henry was
great this other guy's pretty good and
it was and he played a clip where i was
standing up live streaming the occupiers
taking the the orange netflix all right
i remember that yes and to be clear that
was sam's opinion in 2011
i want people to want people to make
sure that there's not like sam
afterwards like he thought tim was just
second rate even then no no i get to
play that every time and be like this is
now this is 2022 right and then you know
i uh you know i don't think you know
knew this till i came on and told you
but when you came on the majority port
i was the producer at the time who
reached out to you and said hey tim you
should come on the show crazy yeah well
here you are man yeah here we are is it
going to be a good conversation we have
a lot
eleven years later eleven years later
we're only by wall street we're old you
know it's crazy yeah you guys are old
well how old are you 27 27
i'm 35. oh okay we're like yeah yeah the
crazy thing is during occupy wall street
it was like just you know 12 or so years
after um the battle in seattle which i
wasn't at because i was too young right
yes and now i'm like 11 years on from
occupy it's a crazy feeling wow but
let's
talk about we also got sheamus my name's
sheamus coughlin i create animated
educational and satirical political
cartoons on a channel called freedom
tunes you all should go over there check
it out we also have an announcement to
make about the platform tonight i'm i'm
sure i'll do it later i don't want to
like derail the entire show with this
exciting announcement we won't really be
able to get any interesting
conversations if i do so but
stay tuned and uh thank you so much for
stopping by the show and i am also here
since ian is out for the full week we're
going to miss him he is traveling and
he's going to be having a great time
hopefully i'm hoping he does traveling
cross country is not always super fun
but hopefully this is good for him and
uh yeah let's read our sponsor there
were there were people who were saying
that like it was funny last week they
were like ian needs a vacation so like
not in a negative way they were like
this guy's been on the show like
non-stop never had like you know very
and then i was like that's really
interesting that they're saying that
cause like ian was playing
yeah and of course he took off as i come
i know i know you know people keep
telling me to take a vacation too and
i'm like never on you know
your audience really cares about me yeah
all right before we get started my
friends head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and secure your
keto elevate from biotrust this is
c8mct oil powder you mix it in your food
and drink it is not a secret because i
basically talk about every time we
promote biotrust that i've lost like 25
pounds since november by cutting out
sugars adding this stuff to my coffee a
lot of fat low sugar cut out bread
basically there's a period where i had
some bread and it just was really awful
so again
eatrightandfeelwell.com and you'll get a
60-day money-back guarantee keto elevate
provides your body only c8 the most
ketogenic mct that means it provides
support for energy levels healthy
appetite management mental clarity and
focus and athletic performance you'll
get five grams of the highly sought
after mctc8 per scoop
free shipping on every order and for
every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids police out biotrust hit
their goal of 6 million meals this year
you'll get free vip live health and
fitness coaching from biotrust's team of
expert nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order and their free
e-report the top 14 ketogenic foods with
every order again
eatrightandfeelwell.com 51 offer don't
forget head over to timcast.com become a
member to support our work as a member
you'll get access to exclusive segments
from the show monday through thursday at
8pm so we'll have one of those going up
tonight and you're also helping keep our
journalists employed so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show if you really do like it now
let's read this first story
the most important story from fox
business
elon musk sends poop emoji to twitter
ceo in response to thread on spam and
fake accounts
twitter has estimated that spam and fake
accounts make up less than five percent
of the social media platform's users
okay i had to lead with the poop emoji
one but the real story is that elon musk
may actually
a deal at a lower price is not out of
the question there's a lot to break down
in this story but basically
elon musk tweeted out a story from may
2nd where twitter filed a report saying
their users was around five five percent
of their users were spam or bots
elon musk the deal was on hold until he
could verify that today the ceo said you
can't verify it because we have internal
data on who people actually are and it's
private that we can't share that's an
interesting point elon mentioned that he
would take a random sampling of 100
users
and then he got accused of like that's a
ridiculous sample size you can't use
that so then he revealed actually this
is
twitter is that's the number they use
then twitter apparently called him or so
he says and accuse him of violating his
nda things are getting crazy i'm not
entirely convinced the deal will go
through my personal opinion is that elon
musk is intending to expose algorithmic
manipulation and potential fraud as it
pertains to bots two things we ended up
learning since this act this this deal
was going through one
twitter misrepresented its user accounts
by i think a couple million on more than
one occasion even the verge question how
could that have happened and then we saw
the strange shift where people
associated with the right libertarians
started gaining tons of followers
particularly people who were associated
with like marjorie taylor green or matt
gates gained a ton but then we saw
barack obama lose a bit we saw katy
perry lose a bit if you were associated
with with the mainstream or the left you
were losing followers now to me my
theory is algorithmic manipulation but
i'm curious what your guys's thoughts
are i don't know matt i mean i think
when it comes to that i think people are
just reacting to the news of elon musk i
think people heard what elon musk was
planning to do in terms of bringing back
ben users specifically one donald trump
and i think you had a number of uh
people who lean left or maybe apolitical
but just don't like donald trump or
people of that uh you know of that
political affiliation um and they
deactivated their account i'm not even
saying they left for good they just
deactivated as a as a protest and um you
know conservatives definitely came back
because they heard elon musk and you say
this a lot conservatives
actually think and i can't say all but
the ones that you see on twitter
randomly like you saw all these uh big
conservative like influencers come on
and go like oh i'm back because the elon
musk and it's like why are you lying to
your followers that's not true you're
not back because of elon musk because
elon musk didn't do anything he doesn't
own twitter yet like they came back they
well you had tucker carlson act like he
came back because he was no he was
suspended i think he was suspended he
acted like he he could have unsuspended
himself at any time he had to delete a
single tweet he chose on the day that
elon musk announced he was going to
purchase all that news came out by elon
musk elon musk purchasing twitter he
decided on that day to tweet that uh i'm
back there were a few others uh who said
that too i can look them up in a second
if you want for sure i'm familiar with
that yeah and it's like why are you
because they know like tucker carlson
knows because he did what charlie kirk's
another one um they he said he was back
he he said he was back on twitter he had
to delete a tweet oh right right right
because they they all had tweeted
something that goes against twitter's
policy well hold on so so right so did
they delete the tweets or they
reinstated no they deleted the tweets
you know that for sure i know that for
sure do you know who the red-headed
libertarian is i'm not familiar with the
russians she's my go-to example of this
one she was suspended in january of 2021
for no reason right like she didn't
break any rules they didn't tell her why
she was suspended but she got reinstated
the following day
sure there were a whole bunch of people
that um you know that that we saw who
were saying things like i was suspended
until now we had people chatting us like
i haven't been on twitter because i've
been banned let me check whoa my
account's back well do they know that it
was back before that for all they know
that suspension could have lifted in the
next months before yeah
it's possible it's anecdotal right i
don't know but we do know we do know
that those big influencers who could
have deleted they weren't suspended and
had nothing they could do to get back on
they specifically were told delete this
offending uh the policy that offends our
uh the tweet that offends our policy
excuse me delete that and you can come
back on that's the rule for certain uh
content that goes against their policy
it's not a full-blown suspension and
they could have done it any time chose
not to and the day elon musk and you
know the news broke
uh he based they basically came back and
decided but you know i i don't think you
can say you know that tucker deleted the
tweet the tweet's not there anymore
maybe they deleted it no they don't do
that they don't do that for that okay
occasionally i i would agree too it does
sound like they deleted the tweet they'd
like definitely
i mean maybe but maybe like it's like
you're saying people joined the platform
because elon was moving in so they were
like okay i'll come back now
yeah they chose to maybe now decide to
delete the tweet sure that could have
been one occasion here's the challenge i
have with with this idea i mean i think
uh we we've talked about it quite a bit
i think fraud and the reason is on the
surface that makes the most sense
twitter said
uh people deactivating their accounts
was organic and and uh i don't think
they i don't know if they commented on
people signing up or joining but when
you take i pulled up my twitter numbers
here we can see that on april 25th
i gained 19 000 on april 27th i gained
39 000 on the 28th 47 000 it's crazy but
on monday the day that the news actually
broke i only gained i only gained a
thousand it was 8 a.m right why did no
one sign up on the day of and why did
they wait to 20
after that i've got no idea i mean
there's something certainly interesting
going on on twitter right now and i've i
you know i don't think anyone could
really explain it why did katy perry
lose 200 000 followers right well i'm
sure she has a user base that's
mainly young millennial gen z and you
know we know from a fact you know that
they're not big fans of donald trump why
why the following monday did twitter put
out its report on its total numbers of
bots and spam the week before we have
this weird thing happen a day after the
sale is announced so you know here
here's my train of thought i don't i
don't think you're you're wrong i think
what i see as being more probable is
monday at 8 a.m they announced they're
in the final discussion
nothing happens it was it was at 2 53
p.m i think they officially announced
that elon 52 maybe had officially
secured the deal
that night something changed so the next
morning massive growth of followers tons
of people you know like aside from
tucker and other people who are like on
suspension to remove a tweet there were
people who were saying that they were
banned and the example that i go to and
again it's anecdotal it's not you know
like more than that the redheaded
libertarian who had created a new
account was banned we don't know why all
of a sudden getting reinstated a year
later but 24 hours after the fact the
drop-off in in followers was the same
thing 24 hours after so i'd imagine that
the morning they announced elon musk was
going to buy the platform people would
have started signing up and coming back
right maybe i mean i i really i don't
think either of us could really speak to
this we just only speculate i mean
because there could have been things
happening behind the scenes at twitter
um there could be external factors where
third parties decided to
literally manipulate it so that people
like you and me would sit here and
pontificate about what could possibly
have happened um i mean we just don't
know that's one of the you know that's
one of the issues and you know i think
the the uh in terms of this particular
story i think the bigger thing here is
you know elon musk knew this information
like he he announced that reuters like
he he
shared that reuters story about the ten
percent less than ten percent
less than five percent was it five i'm
pretty sure was ten five that might be
five okay uh whatever the percentage was
there we go i got axios well under five
percent okay so he had that information
that under five percent uh were spam
uh but the reuters story he shared
that's from the twitter filing that he
had already in the prior week or two
when he announced he was to buy twitter
like he knew this he had their filing
before they filed he he knew no he knew
the information he was let in obviously
on what
he had to make a decision on whether to
buy the company or not so they would let
him they would let them know what their
projections are or what their you know
what their their finances where
where did you hear that well they would
it's part of the it's part of the deal
that's where it's from it's it's like
it's in the it's in the deal itself it
says that we gave elon information on
these things he had all he had a bunch
of information how he makes the info
that's how he makes the determination to
buy the company sounds like he didn't
have that information and that's why
he's raising an issue i mean perhaps i
mean it's weird that he would you know
it's weird that he would go about doing
this and then because me personally i
thought you know a lot of people were
worried that elon musk would um you know
change twitter and that's what that's
why people left and that's why there was
all this i don't i'm not worried about
twitter uh in terms of elon musk doing
horrible things to like content
moderation like maybe he will maybe he
won't i think he's just mostly a hype
man he likes the attention he likes to
say a lot of things and not you know not
deliver um i think the biggest threat to
twitter when it comes to elon musk is he
seems to not understand social media he
doesn't understand the business of
social media at all if you look at his
ideas to generate revenue he wants users
to pay to use twitter it's not going to
happen well i think he said high profile
years or so if individuals using twitter
would not have to pay for it but if you
were a larger brand or a government you
would have to pay some kind of fee well
i would definitely do that i mean maybe
you would but there's also a lot of
companies that just wouldn't
uh basic like users who would be
influential like the idea that everyone
who's uh who's got a blue check mark or
anyone who's got a lot of followers is
automatically someone of means or
something like that it's just three
bucks for a month just i mean three
dollars people people wouldn't you
people wouldn't pay people wouldn't i i
think they would i mean the what he's
talking about is a suite of tools and
access to fix problems and to help the
high profile customers i think he's
right um i think if you look at
uh most digital services they offer a
hey if you know you pay this premium
package we'll give you access to this
these back-end tools these analytics and
things like that like we pay for a bunch
of google tools like i have multiple
google reps for all the different stuff
we use we have nothing like that for
twitter i've even bought twitter ads and
there's like no one to talk to right
because twitter users don't necessarily
uh react to twitter ads it's not the
same business model oh they do they do i
got a million hits on my song by putting
it by buying an ad for it right for real
no but there's there's all sorts of
different types of advertisements i mean
just look at twitter's revenue it's
nowhere near the amount that you know
facebook or google makes it's just not
the same audience they just do when
you're making the case for elon how many
companies being run really bad oh no no
no doubt about it yeah twitter twitter i
was talking about this with someone
earlier uh in terms of the big tech
companies twitter was the most
susceptible to something like this
um you know elon can't afford google
exactly or you know and can't afford
facebook he can't afford you know any
apple amazon microsoft they're well
beyond the amount he could he could
barely even do twitter he needs to bring
a whole bunch of people on board uh i
need to sell he needs to sell tesla
stock um but but it was the it's the one
um platform that's in this realm
that has the same sort of cachet as
those other platforms like when you
think of the big tech platforms you
throw twitter in there even though
they're nowhere near as big when you
look behind the curtain they're the most
important though
in a sense in a sense it's the depending
on what your niche is depending what
your industry is
in terms of media and news for sure but
i'm sure if you talk to people outside
those industries again we're in this
bubble here so to us we probably i mean
i use twitter more than anything else
too yeah um we're definitely in a bubble
i think that's a problem with a lot of
things going on people are in a bubble
and they don't realize that they're
basically you know just taking
information as they see it through their
own lens and there's whole other worlds
on other platforms even on twitter
there's whole other worlds that you
probably don't don't even know who tim
poole is period oh for sure yeah yeah
i've i've tracked the there's a really
cool mapping thing they do
they've made multiple where it shows you
like the different universes on twitter
and how they can connect and some don't
there's like a cluster of people that's
really small that has zero connection to
the rest of the platform in any way and
it's the weirdest thing and i i've seen
one where there's like a couple users
and i'm just like what are they talking
to figure out what they're doing what
are they doing over there by themselves
uh
i i think though it's it's the most
important because
it is uh it's the town square facebook
isn't facebook is oh that's what twitter
brands itself as for sure right so so
twitter is you know news stories they
got you tim no they do no they're for
sure um i mean i started on twitter
because of occupying a way to get news
out really quick and because people who
do news and politics use it it's become
influential in the space of mutual
politics and because it is
that's why you unwanted libs of tick
tock is setting policy
now cool for sure i mean
they repost these videos and all of a
sudden it's impacting laws in other
states so twitter facebook doesn't do
that right youtube i mean they'll do it
a little bit because they're information
platforms that have influence but
twitter man i mean so so many have
argued this i mean people people at
corporate press facebook does
disseminate information to people who'd
be more likely to um believe in
something they read online based on you
know uh
it being falsified or you know not
factual um simply because they seem to
be
the more common everyday uh user in
terms of like your parents yeah your
parents are on facebook you know family
members use facebook for all sorts of
different reasons and people share
things on facebook that uh you know that
they just sort of passively read or or
uh you know uh take in and they just
shared people that follow them on
facebook well and i think you kind of
hit the nail on the head there when you
discussed family specifically a huge
part of why people use facebook based on
my own experience and the reason people
use instagram is because they're keeping
in touch with people around them whereas
with platforms like twitter and youtube
yeah they're also social media platforms
but they're much more about seeking
information from complete strangers or
people who you've come to trust over the
years because you like their you know
angle on things sure yeah let's talk
about this story we got from project
veritas that broke just a moment ago we
have this um from project veritas i
tweeted out breaking from veritas
twitter employee confirms bias at
twitter and i'll give you my opinion uh
seems i was right because conservative
because conservatives tolerate leftist
speech and leftists won't tolerate the
right twitter opts to censor the right
as balance so i'll play a bit of this
and you can hear from himself
[Music]
right
i don't know if the two parties can
truly coexist on one platform what do
your colleagues say about like
they hate it oh my god i'm at least like
okay with it but some of my colleagues
are like super
left left
left left left what do they say
they're like this will be my last day if
it happens
as much change since so i'll pause it
there i think we all know the stories
about the political leanings of people
at twitter's uh stance if elon gets
hired they're like we're out but for me
when i saw this what i found interesting
was uh what i've said before is
it's a business decision you got to take
a look at it from twitter's perspective
people like ben shapiro are memed for
saying debate me right they the the
right wants to own the libs they want to
be on twitter they want to argue with
liberals so they like seeing these
tweets libs of tick tock is a really
good example libs of tic-tac re-posts
the things the left says like see hey
look at this
on the left however they're the ones
that are flagging they're the ones
saying these people should be banned uh
you mentioned earlier that uh some of
these people had violated the rules and
that they had been suspended yeah sure
they could they could come back
so my point uh you know a couple weeks
ago was if twitter is confronted with
this from a business perspective they're
going to say the right doesn't care if
the left is saying things as much the
left does care if the right is saying
things so purely from a business
perspective well we'll ban as many on
the right as we can without disrupting
as many users as possible and then we
don't got to ban the left because the
right's not going to do anything about
it anyway well i mean twitter has a very
clear well first of all i just want to
say that libs of tick-tock there's a
little bit more than just reposting uh
what uh leftists say on tick tock we
could get into that maybe in a little
bit but uh on this topic um
you know uh
twitter has a pretty clear set of rules
and guidelines on their website and uh
it seems like
uh
maybe just right-wing accounts break
those policies more so than left-wing
accounts i know plenty of people who got
banned or suspended from twitter for
just literally saying like uh you know
[ __ ] you or uh you know
you know something like that and they
get the you know this is not uh part of
the twitter policy that you're suspended
for you know people who got spent not
even just to delete the tweet and come
back people who got spend it outright
had to start new accounts for something
like that uh there's you know are you
familiar with learn to code yes so they
were the editor-in-chief of the daily
caller was commenting on on on the
phenomenon and got suspended for it so
there were there were tons of people and
i think this may be what we're seeing
come back with the the big surge and
right-wing users at least partly we also
have to be careful with this video here
uh project veritas has a uh a long
history of
uh disseminating edited footage well i
mean everybody post edited footage no i
mean edited footage that comp i mean
they got sued by uh people who lost
their job uh they're probably his big
you know uh james acorn when acorn went
out when a horse closed down because
james o'keefe released that pimp video
if you recall that yeah uh he got sued
and he lost because there was more video
to it and everything he said that this
woman didn't you know didn't do she
actually went ahead and did she he had
to pay her he had to pay i think he
settled that i don't think he lost but
you could call it a loss in terms of if
you settle well has he has he lost
anything since he formed project veritas
um
maybe we have to check the answer is no
he hasn't maybe he hasn't and uh so you
know like we've had james on the show we
talked about it he said settling was the
biggest mistake he made because they
weren't wrong but i want to put words in
his mouth because i can't speak to to
this this was uh before he formed
veritas
since veritas has been around they've
not lost i'm pretty sure they've not
lost a single lawsuit in fact they've
won over and over and over again
yeah and there's a whole wall of all the
news organizations who have backed down
and rescinded everything so i'm pretty
sure he's not lost anything yeah and i
that that uh lawsuit was not necessarily
just about them claiming they were
misrepresented a lot of it had to do
with california's two-party consent laws
with respect to recording somebody was
that it yeah california's two-party
consent look i'm i'm not um uh i think
my issue with the veritas stuff and the
arguments against him uh easily
exemplified by
i think it was channel 4 in the uk did
the exact same thing veritas does and it
was just heaps of praise all across the
media a deceptive like they they lied to
the targets they go in and they say like
here's who we are and it's not true and
then they secretly record them and then
they publish it on the news and it was
praised by all the big mainstream
publications that's exactly what veritas
does
so if you do undercover reporting then i
mean i don't see what the issue is in
this settlement uh james o'keefe claimed
he was unaware that uh the woman who was
suing him uh literally did everything
that he claimed that she didn't she
called the police the second he came in
and he
she warned uh them about what was going
on and what she was experiencing and i
mean that was the that was the main when
this happened this was in uh 2013. and
was that project veritas or james
o'keefe
uh i guess it was james o'keefe i mean
james o'keefe is project veritas have
you uh so
look let's let's just say uh
james o'keefe 10 years ago i mean he
also he did also he also no but he also
did that thing where that was there was
the um
that um person who was dropping off uh
ballots in um i think it was uh
minnesota minnesota and the person came
out and said that he completely
distorted that he said they're on video
doing it
but that's no but that's but that's
legal that's okay to do what he was
doing no it's not it is you could drop
off ballots that's what happened man we
got to pull up all the sources uh yeah
he had a car full of ballots and said he
was what do you say he was getting paid
to drop him off
i mean that's that that's illegal well
let's let me look it up so yeah yeah
yeah because you said that so so but
i'll put it this way let's let's um
uh
we'll pull that up because i want to
make sure we have that we have it all
correct and everything i know that there
were there were accusations against uh
james over that one but my issue is just
like
how many stories has project veritas put
out how many how many real substantive
issues have people criticized him over
and then i'll say
first of all
i'll put it this way
i'm pretty sure that was illegal because
we covered that extensively and we did
we went through all the laws and stuff
we can i don't know if sheamus wants to
look up you can look it up too and we'll
make sure we get the facts right but uh
man
i don't understand why
all of this is directed at a handful of
stories veritas does when you have every
other day fake news coming out of the
washington post out of the new york
times out of cnn huge stories too there
were years long spans of lies and
manipulations some that result into
major lawsuits too like you know we
still use cnn the washington post and
the new york times despite the covington
kids lawsuits that they're all being
stood over and losing because we
recognize that news organizations get
things wrong unless there's evidence to
suggest something was not correct about
it i don't understand why
we would not just hold the scrutiny of
any organization uh uh oh absolutely
that includes yeah everyone in media
yeah so when you know cnn or the new
york times can come out and say sources
say
or people familiar with trump's thinking
have confirmed i'm just like
yo the news the news like mainstream
press rolls with those and veritas
published a video now by all means you
can say the video is deceptively edited
if you don't believe it's true
but
new york times doesn't even put out who
their sources are at the time well i
mean that's basic journalism you could
not trust corporate media if you would
like so what if j but they're but
they're but they're surely they're
surely uh well respected specific
reporters and journalists who have a
track record of good work what if james
o'keefe instead of revealing the video
just said we have a source within
twitter who has said this thing
well
james o'keefe is a known liar based on
what we've previously heard about the
settlements and stuff so i mean um you
better be hold on i gotta tell you uh
back that up
i mean he paid a settlement a hundred
thousand dollars this woman and he
admitted that he
lied about what she said on the video
as long as you're saying that that's
true and you're willing to stand behind
it i mean like he said it he said it i'm
just saying his settlement he said it in
his settlement i'm just saying that
because james has basically sued every
single person who has accused him and
he's won every single case i mean if he
wants to
dispute the fact that he paid this woman
a hundred thousand dollars because he
said that he claimed that you know she
didn't call the police when he came in
with his pimp suit claiming what he
claimed um and she did and he said he
didn't know but
she he put the video out didn't ask her
i guess afterwards
you know i can i can
we can say yes like it was wrong james
did a bad thing but i mean i mean how
does that discredit the story what story
the the twitter story all i'm saying is
we don't know the whole the whole uh
conversation that went on there i agree
with that for sure um
so we have to go by what it's also it's
also like honestly a very like low bore
i mean so the the the um the accusation
is that what that leftists won't
tolerate the right i mean well that's
one of them okay but i mean they're just
they're just basically what are they
doing they're reporting a tweet
for something that this right-winger
said that would either a
not break twitter policies so there
would be no punishment let's talk about
the word policy there would then be
misgendering policies regenerating
policy yep that's swedish policy yeah
yeah yeah absolutely and it's it's
biased against conservatives how is it
biased against conservatives
conservatives don't agree with the
concept of misgendering i mean
not a single one right i mean it's basic
respect if you ask me it doesn't matter
if i'm not i'm not if you ask you're
coming from a left-wing perspective sure
but it's not i'm not making a moral
statement i'm saying conservatives don't
agree with the concept of misgendering
right that's a fact i mean
maybe there are conservatives that don't
i mean i do agree well but i mean do you
think conservatives agree with the
concept of misgendering i mean vast
majority yeah sure you think they they
agree that misgendering is a thing no no
they agree that they should have the
right to misgender someone right they
don't believe it exists you you view it
as they think they should be allowed to
but conservatives don't think it's a
thing right so you've got you've got how
many with 74 million trump voters
i'd say the overall majority are like
either don't know what it even means or
if you look at the staunch conservatives
would outright say well we have to we
have to we have to be very specific here
about i'm all for someone learning and
understanding and using the wrong
language i mean i know plenty of people
on the left i do myself sometimes i use
the wrong pronoun or whatever for
someone who uh you know does not
identify as that gender and if someone's
coming at it in good faith and not
meaning to you know to harm somebody or
be you know
be well
i don't want to deviate too much i mean
i mean the issue you brought up that
there's conservatives who don't even
know that's a thing now if one of those
conservatives does that thing on twitter
and then someone's just like hey you're
misgendering me and then they're just
like oh i'm sorry or just we're just
dude i mean
people say dude all the time and zooby
got banned for it he got a suspension
for saying okay dude well
in what context did he say i mean he's
not someone who doesn't know what
misgendering is he's someone who's
clearly considering he's saying dude in
a for in an informal context like we say
dude
here's the point here's the point you're
making moral statement i'm making more
i'm not making a moral statement we know
conservatives don't agree we know the
left does twitter has a policy that the
left agrees with the right doesn't
therefore twitter has a policy biased
against the right that's that's that's
that's a a simple fact statement i mean
if you're some if you're coming from if
you're coming from the position that um
if you don't agree that this is the
thing i mean well then i mean
twitter is saying it's a thing like it's
their platform they're saying this is
the thing
you're misunderstanding how am i
misunderstanding it i'm not making a
moral statement okay i'm not saying
twitter is right or wrong
twitter is well within its rights to
have whatever rules it wants sure
conservatives disagree with the concept
uh progressives agree with the policy
twitter's rules
suit the view of the left and not the
right
that's simply true twitter's deciding to
make those rules i mean absolutely we
agree on that yeah okay so if
conservatives don't agree with those
rules twitter's rule set is biased
against the conservative worldview i
mean there's all sorts of rules i don't
agree with too but it doesn't mean
they're biased against my worldview this
is just what they do i mean
the misgendering thing is is clearly cut
obviously if we can if we want to
nitpick you can talk about the the
various right-wing factions i mean if
you don't if you don't agree that trans
people exist when they clearly do then i
don't know what to tell you i don't know
who said that on the right
i mean i'm on the right look i i don't
believe in the concept of transgenderism
i don't believe there's a difference
between gender and sex and i would say
that tim is making a descriptive
statement he's not saying that it's good
or bad that twitter has this specific
policy he's just saying that on the
issue of transgenderism twitter has
clearly taken a side and their side is
that a person's gender identity is a
concept which supersedes their
biological identity okay that's a
decision they made as a platform which
is a politically biased decision i mean
they're basically saying trans people
exist though because if you take that
away then what is i mean what are you i
don't know i'm not quite i mean i know
what you're arguing but you're basically
saying it's biased against conservatives
to admit that trans people exist but
that's not what they're doing
yeah
they're not saying trump people exist
they're saying you are forced to
acknowledge that you believe this
identity is their identity even if you
don't agree with that then or else
you're not on the platform yeah because
that's what the misgendering policy is
they're not even saying that they're
saying you have to use this language or
we will ban you okay conservatives say
i do not believe in the use of that
language and it's overt i mean it i
would say
99 out of 100 conservatives would be
like i'm not going to use preferred
pronouns if twitter's rules
are in line with your worldview or a
progressive worldview they're biased
against conservatives i don't think
we're arguing i think we agree on that i
mean i i don't think it's biased
conservatives be quite honest but we
could go in circles on this or we could
just you know it's up to you so you
think conservatives
are
you're not making you're not making
sense man i mean what do you mean if you
basically tell somebody we know
conservatives like don't use the concept
of misgendering we we know conservatives
will call a trans woman he right yes
therefore twitter's rules do not
are are are not fitting what
conservatives do and think on a daily
basis
i mean
it is over it is like
it's one plus one equals two it's like
just right there in front of you i mean
you could argue that about anything
though like what i mean like what like
you can't say the n-word on twitter and
and do conservatives want to say the end
yeah oh they don't oh please they do
see not all conservatives but they're
the subsection of twitter that does want
to is certainly on the right there are
people who like using bad words on the
right there are people who like using
bad words on the left
if you wanna like we're not gonna i'm
not gonna make a blanket statement that
every leftist wants to advocate for
antifa going and killing people but
there are certainly aunties that go
around advocating for killing people
right
how many people have advocated for
killing libs of tiktok a large amount we
can pull up tweets how many people have
advocated for
serious physical harm to andy no i'm not
going to sit here and say everyone on
the left wants to violently harm you
know andy no oh there are people who did
it there are good and bad people the
issue is if you go to some of the most
prominent conservatives like ben shapiro
he will say i do not use preferred
pronouns sure he's got one of the top
podcasts in the world and twitter's
rules
conflict with one of the biggest
possibilities you don't you don't you
don't have to use someone's pronouns at
all though i mean you could easily talk
about that individual by their name
right i mean but i might make like i
said i'm not making a moral statement if
ben shapiro wants to say he he's told he
can't or he'll be banned well i mean
that's just twitter's rules twitter's
right twitter's rules fit the leftist
worldview well i mean if a if a
left-winger also wants to do that then
they can't either right but the left
tends to agree with that perspective
it's the leftist worldview or it's a
component i mean yes left people agree
that trans people exist i mean arguing
they don't exist why do you keep saying
that because if you're not gonna if
you're not gonna basically uh
acknowledge someone's gender identity
then you're saying they're not trans
people don't exist but what does that
mean trans people don't exist i mean
that someone's not trans what do you
mean what
so
sheamus can argue what do you say
transgenderism doesn't exist or what
yeah i don't believe gender and sex are
i don't believe like in the concept of
gender it was developed the coin was for
the the term was first coined by dr john
money who was like a pedophile and sex
pervert who abused children and created
this idea that we can make um this this
false distinguishing between a person's
actual biological sex and the sex they
should be treated as within society i
don't think it's a legitimate concept i
believe and i agree that there are
people
who struggle with their identity i think
there are people who are deeply confused
about their sexual identity i do not
believe a man can ever become a woman or
that a woman can ever become a man i
don't yes
that's what you believe all right but i
mean i don't know the information that
you just said in terms of i can look it
up but um
uh you know people do suffer from gender
disorders yeah that's a real that's a
right that's a real thing absolutely and
every everybody agrees those people
exist yes so why do you keep saying
trans people don't exist because
you're saying
that gender dysphoria
exists yes
but you're saying that the actual
outcome what they're looking to do to
actually uh treat their gender dysphoria
it's not a real thing well no no no no
no no yes yes that's what trans people
exist and will
and i've met trump supporting uh trans
women
sure and and hackers and leftists and
right-wingers of course they exist of
course gender is real they're trans
women they have preferred pronouns and
whether or not you compel someone to use
those words has nothing to do with
saying they exist or not
if you refuse to use anyone's pronouns
or just refuse to even call them by
their name i mean i don't just i mean i
don't know what to say to you i mean i
mean if i called you floorbo would that
be denying your existence if you called
me floorbow yeah if i'm if i used a
pronoun for you that wasn't your
preferred pronoun am i denying your
existence i mean personally it wouldn't
bother me but that's just me am i
denying your existence are you denying
my existence i mean people could argue
disrespectful for sure but am i denying
your existence well because trans people
don't
uh acknowledge that they have that their
their uh you know their birth name or
given name is what they you know that's
not them
i'm i'm
do you i don't know i don't know what to
say i mean you're saying
they're claiming trans people don't
exist that's like a buzz phrase with no
meaning you've conveyed no idea to
anyone what are you talking about what
idea are you trying to convey
when you say conservatives say trans
people don't exist what is that supposed
to mean what that's supposed to mean if
you're you're all right let's go let's
go let's go back to the original thing
that you were talking about twitter's
policy and you're saying it's
purposefully um i didn't say obviously
okay that's biased no moral statement
sure it is a rule set that the world the
left agrees through the right doesn't
and therefore is biased against the
conservative worldview okay and if
twitter did not have that policy then it
would be biased against trans people no
it would be well no it would be unbiased
right if twitter had a policy which said
um if twitter had no policy on what
pronouns you could use for someone that
would not be biased that would just be
like the lack of a policy altogether
yeah the left
lack of policy could be biased no no no
the inversion would be twitter saying
you are not allowed to use preferred
pronouns right
so once what the conservatives don't
want to refer to trans women by she her
right okay they could just not refer to
trans women that way so but you'll get
banned on twitter just
you do not have to go after a trans
person so here's my point if you can
exist on twitter without attacking a
trans person twitter calling them but
again this is this is a left-wing
framing that it's attacking someone to
not use the pronouns that affirm this
idea that they're there's something that
they're not
the point the point is the rules it's if
i started calling you she for example
that would be completely incorrect
because i'm not a woman i'm a man i've
been a man in my whole life and even if
i decided to identify as a woman i still
would not become a woman but i would
have the point if but if you did though
out of the common respect to refer to
you by your gender identity so i i
absolutely believe that you are coming
at this from a place of respect but i
don't think it's respectful to indulge
something that's not well hold on hold
on hold on we're deviating way too far
the point is
twitter's rules overtly biased if
twitter removed the rule there would be
no bias because there's no rule
if twitter created a rule that said
trans people are not allowed to use
preferred pronouns that would be biased
in favor of conservatives
if twitter
also made a rule that said that you know
you can now use the n-word who do you
think that affects who's that biased
against that's biased against people who
uh black people yes right yes but is
there a policy saying you're a like the
the issue
the issue is
twitter uh negative rights positive
rights uh et cetera et cetera twitter is
saying here is a list of things you
can't do and it tends to be things
conservatives do right
okay i'm sorry that conservatives do
things that tend to disrespect people i
mean that's that's that's i'm not making
a moral judgment if you want to say
they're they're disrespecting people i
don't care i'm simply saying twitter's
rule set favor is the leftist approach
all right and i disagree but that's
that's that's impossible i'm not making
i'm not making an opinion statement i'm
making a fact statement i i just don't
agree i mean we know from just how these
social media platforms we take twitter
specifically how they work
they tend to the algorithm tends to um
write uh uh
platform content on the right all the
time well they platform everybody all
the time no no you get you they
recommend right-wing content more often
than not that's 100 who does
uh any social media platform
facebook
um twitter
you are wrong
uh let me let me try the tube's another
one yeah uh let me let me try and pull
up the uh
see if i can find the article you know
one of the challenges with doing these
like we sit down and we talk about is
we're always trying to you know figure
out where we saw something and all that
stuff
so let me see if i can uh
find this oh do you want me to buy this
mukrak is trying to sell me the article
uh let me see if i can try and find this
article it's by a researcher named mark
ledwich
twitter algorithm's bias toward
right-wing content says who twitter's
own research and what and what did they
say and why did they say uh twitter is
publicly sharing research findings today
this is from protocol uh that show that
the platform's algorithms amplify tweets
from right-wing politicians and content
from right-wing news outlets more than
people and content from the political
left
uh
there you go
i'm trying to pull up this mark ledwich
thing so i see this from the washington
post october 22nd 2021 twitter
algorithms amplify conservative content
more than that of the political left
researchers fine who are the researchers
an internal evaluation of twitter's
recommendation algorithms concluded that
they amplify right-leaning political
content more than left-leaning content
company researchers announced thursday
undercutting allegations by many
conservatives who contend they are being
censored on the platform now that
statement is is just confusing and
factually incorrect twitter can promote
conservatives but doesn't mean you know
she goes to a bomber of this elon musk
why don't you ask him to uh find out
more information about this stunning
agreed
if conservatives are complaining about
being censored the fact that twitter
promotes some conservatives doesn't mean
conservatives aren't being censored the
fact that twitter would promote more
conservatives doesn't mean some
conservatives aren't being censored so
it's washington post's point
but uh
we'd have to
the research and months of the making
part of twitter's promise to evaluate
evaluate the underpinnings blah blah
blah i'm trying to see what the meat of
what they're actually saying is and i
don't seem it doesn't seem to be in the
article they said they analyzed millions
of 2020 tweets by elected officials in
seven countries canada france germany uh
okay so it's not an american thing as
well as post that oh come on
all right i can debunk this in two
seconds for you okay go ahead
all right from the new york times what
happens to america's political center of
gravity as you can see the right-leaning
uh platforms the right-leaning political
parties in europe are to the left of the
republican party so when you say twitter
is amplifying right-wing content it's
like okay okay in america yes or no the
answer is no because the parties that
were getting amplified european parties
are to the left of the republican party
i mean so you so it's to the right of
you that's a fair point it's to the left
of the american uh conservative well
that's a major statement that you have
to probably check with uh you know the
researchers who put together this study
um well they specific well i'm showing
you right here
you specifically yourself i mean um
have what 1.2 million twitter followers
right yeah and what what am i what's my
what's my political affiliation oh your
critical affiliation right why did you
talk about that right um yeah i mean i
don't think you are exactly what you
claim you are what am i um you know i
would say you're pretty much
conservative what makes me conservative
what makes you uh a liberal
uh well traditional liberals in this
country uh specifically social liberal
uh is where i've always been voted for
obama in 2008. a lot of people voted for
obama in 2008 and then moved over to
trump we've established that so i voted
for trump in 2020 yeah there you go
right so uh traditional liberals all
those liberals who voted for trump nine
million in this country that's right
consider them liberal and substantially
more uh donald trump is democrats not
liberals no they're liberal uh donald
trump is a new york new york liberal
like donald trump unfurled an lgbt flag
on the rnc stage
and got republicans to clap for it oh
sure okay so uh i'm pro-choice uh well
we could talk about that yeah i'm
pro-progressive tax uh i'm pro-green new
deal
are you
oh yes really absolutely really i don't
think you watched the show i know i have
watched the show i've seen you
completely come out and get really mad
at uh alexandria ocasio-cortez for yeah
do you mean like free college for black
people
what did you read no i did but that's
that that's what bothers you uh what
bothers me is that when i advocate for
environmental policy having worked for
several environments and i don't think
and also i don't think the policy says
free college for black people no no it's
it's it's free college it's free health
care for marginalized and oppressed
communities
what does that have to do with wind
turbines what are you talking about is
everything to do with the environmental
situation we're going to be in no that's
race policy no it's not who do you what
do you think happens
when climate change affects the united
states of america who do you think is
going to be the most affected by it
who's not going to be able like ben
shapiro said who's not going to be able
to just get up sell their house that's
going sailing out to the sea and going
underwater like ben shapiro said
who's going to be able to
easily
get themselves out of a situation that
sees their neighborhood getting flooded
their neighbor they're you know
they're going to lose what they
currently have it's not going to be the
wealthy it's not going to be people who
are in comfortable situations we just
get up and move it's going to be people
who don't have means
so when we lift people out of poverty
we'll be able to more uh better address
climate change issues when they arise
just just to go back real quick i did
find the data showing that youtube
overwhelmingly uh sends content to the
left
um and not the right so that you have to
send this to me because this goes
against every piece of research i've
ever read about youtube
i i will i will say outright one of the
challenges with any kind of political
debate is that you're going to
everyone's going to find their sources
you know well where's your source from
this is firstmonday.org this is an
academic named mark ledwich who worked
with a series of other academics
they've mapped out look they got me as
anti-sjw here with sargon of akkad and
what they did was they they grouped
everything by a whole bunch of different
um channels there's like white
identitarian there's partisan right
there's conspiracy there's social
justice there's center left mainstream
media and then they created parents for
what typically
socially falls into a left or right
category and then they created
this uh recommendation trend map showing
you
partisan left content typically
recommends partisan left content
center content typically recommends
partisan i'm sorry typically recommend
center content however when we're
talking about who's getting recommended
the most
from the center you're more likely twice
or three times as likely to get partisan
left content than partisan right content
so if you what do they consider
left-wing content uh socialist social
justice what partisan left what what is
that like what are we talking about here
though because there's right-wingers and
there's all sorts of people who view nbc
and cnn and other corporate that's
that's
mainstream media okay well that's center
left mainstream media okay
center slash left main stream oh it's
its own categories so so they mean like
your tv networks the news they report
and like overwhelmingly anti-trump for
instance uh comedy specials and things
like that if you go on youtube and you
watch jimmy kimmel you are the most
likely to just see more jimmy kimmel
but when it comes to the political
direction new information flows as you
can see from marklight which is research
and there's a couple other researchers
sorry if i'm not reading their names uh
you i mean it looks like
three or four to one you're more likely
to get partisan left-wing content than
right-wing content well that goes
through also every research app here's
one for example now check this out check
it out also if you are watching partisan
right wing content you are more likely
to be recommended center or mainstream
content than if you were on the left in
for the same number it's it seems
somewhat comparable but considering the
partisan left receives 99.5 million
daily impressions to the partisan right
68.6 that's a disproportionate amount of
recommendations in favor of partisan
left all right well i need to see that
study in front of me because i could
easily just pull up another one that
just says you know more than 330 000
videos and nearly 350 youtube channels
were analyzed and manually classified uh
labeled as either media or what we think
of as factual news alt light
intellectual dark red or alt-right and
then it found that uh youtube's
algorithm funnels people to alt-right
videos but by by how much i mean it
doesn't matter that's a face statement
it absolutely does now twitter um
diminished alt-right channels and banned
most of them
they cut them all off from the
recommendation algorithm so the time
period in which youtube did that uh that
study would be important but also yeah
absolutely youtube recommends everything
youtube does recommend alt-right content
for sure they banned a lot of it uh the
issue is in in large amounts like
if a regular person goes on youtube and
watches jimmy kimmel
are they more likely to fall into a left
or right wing rabbit hole the data shows
the left
all right yeah i mean that's that study
is true but but i mean look look but i
mean how often is someone who's watching
jimmy kimmel going and looking for more
political videos i'm assuming they're
going to be looking for entertainment
content right which is why the
overwhelming majority so so if you look
at the left
on this chart for those that are
watching can you pull it up
so if you look on the left you can see
there's a purple bar on the right is
another purple bar
the purple going straight across that
represents the overwhelming majority of
people who watch center or left
mainstream media will only be
recommended center or left mainstream
media when you look on the left you see
this this line going down
that represents how many people from a
mainstream media video will go to a
partisan left video as you can see the
the line representing the data is
substantially larger going to the left
than the right when you look at from a
partisan right wing video to the center
the line is comparable from the partisan
left to the center meaning
partisan right gets two-thirds gets
sixty percent of what uh uh sixty-eight
percent of what the left gets in terms
of views but has an equal amount of
people being recommended away from
partisan right-wing content showing the
left is favored whether inadvertently or
on purpose on youtube so we can talk
about twitter we can talk about the
stuff and again i will stress to
everybody who's watching or listening
we've had conversations we had allad
aliyahu on and he pulled up pew which
said most people are pro-choice and then
i pulled up gallop which said most
people want restrictions on abortion
you're always going to find some data
and it's and it's hard to know what's
true but everybody has their way well
there is an issue i just came up i just
found about this specific study that
you're talking about this is the one
mark ledwich right
okay um
basically let me pull up exactly what we
got here okay to examine what youtube's
algorithm recommends to viewers
lead witch and zaitsev went through
those channels videos and scraped each
one's recommendation data so they were
able to see what youtube offered in the
up next box to people watching each
video however lead witch and zaitsev
crucially did this while not logged into
a youtube account because youtube had no
personalization data to go off of each
box of up next recommendations that
served lead witch and sitesev was a
generalized blank slate collection of
videos the algorithm is literally
incapable of introducing an anonymous
logged out user to increasingly radical
content this is from tubefilter how many
how many of youtube's viewers are logged
in and have accounts oh we should check
that out too so the issue is this
reaches i'm talking about has nothing to
do with it i mean it's literally the
average person will they be fed left
under right-wing content and that
doesn't disprove anything i said
so basically nor does it provide any
evidence in the contrary i mean it looks
like if that you're logged in that uh
based on user data and recommendation
data then it does seem like they funnel
to people to more right-wing content
based what's your studies but the study
i brought before what study well i just
i mentioned it before you know one of
the issues too is we're both we're going
to run into this and i don't think we'll
have an answer for this is
who's doing the study there was a study
that uh
like
will will say something not true about
me or not true about you
if they're trying to get their whatever
outcome they want this is this is the
big challenge with trying to figure out
data in this regards there was a study
that came out that claimed i was like
uh like and capped far right or
something which is just like i don't
even know how they come up with that i
mean come on if someone wants to accuse
me of being a conservative based on
modern tribalism we'll have an argument
but
ancap right-wing i was just like
so i can wait hold on hold on i just
came out because i looked up the i
looked up the author of the study mark
ledwich yeah i mean he
he has a um
looks like he's a q a defender
i don't i don't i don't i mean it seems
like i i mean i wouldn't trust someone
who believes in a conspiracy theory like
queue and not honestly what about
russiagate um yeah what about russiagate
why what does russia get to do with it
what does kyon have to do with what
we're talking about
the author of the study you're citing
seems to be a q non-believer and and
what about the studies you want to
reference look
if i reference the study that uh
reference the study give me the name
we'll pull up their q and on bs come on
what are you talking about i mean you
write your writes a study you
the study sure if you want me to told
you
and want me to pull up their twitter
account and find the stupid things
they've posted this is it look humanon
is not just like posting something
stupid q9 is a whole belief set people's
whole world views what is that what is
what did he defend what did he defend
um let's bring it up right now i'll
bring up the whole long medium blog blog
post here um
let's see we got uh
in the past few months
facebook twitter and youtube have been
waging a war against q anon
um a leviant of a conspiracy theory that
uh explains among other things that
there's a deep state cabal of jewish
satanist globalist democratic elites in
government business and the media
secretly controlling the world and
running a global style check sex
trafficking ring
most recently q9 fans have claimed that
kovit 19 is a hoax that the u.s election
was rigged against donald trump
social media giants recognizing these
conspiracies were gobbling up a lot of
engagement on their sites took action
and censoring them
uh and then he goes on where do you
defend them so it doesn't sound like he
believes in it at all he referred to it
as a conspiracy theory and then he also
said well yeah
no no no no no no no no do you defend
him come on pull that out sure where did
he defend these guys
i don't think he did well i'm looking
through that it's a long piece yeah he
didn't he didn't defend them
mark ludwig oh here we go here we go q
and on believers have already
demonstrated their ability to do this
very well talking about um basically uh
getting content out there and uh you
know um getting their content out there
even when they're already banned from
facebook how is that defending hold on
uh when they hijack the hashtags save
the children uh save the children and
save our children a fundraiser for
anti-trafficking charity i mean that's
not what those two things were for those
who are saying he's wrong he's wrong
about those were not fundraisers for
trafficking
come on come on what i just said he
defended q anon and then you read an
academic piece where he talked about
them not in favor of them no no i just
told you how he called the
hashtag the the slogans they use online
he called them a fundraiser for
anti-trafficking charity and what i
think didn't he say they hijacked a
hashtag which was for an
anti-trafficking cherokee like they or
charity like they stole it from right
they stole it from them um that's not
what i how i'm reading this but maybe it
is let me read it again
uh i i it seems he's not a defender of q
and on dude i mean i've talked to this
guy he's not even political okay he's
like if you talk to him and that means
something you could give a uh that's why
i talked to him because when he did the
research and pulled it up i asked him
for comments and to clarify clarify and
and and that's what we talked about
so
look i i will absolutely concede the
issue is
like i mentioned we had a lot on he's
cool dude and he referenced when it came
to abortion pew research data and i was
like well that conflicts with what i
read and i pulled up gallup and gallup
had a different phrasing which was
slightly different and then i was like
you know what man the challenge is
everybody's fighting over politics and
trying to win and you're going to get
researchers who try and argue both sides
so like if i show you a researcher who
says
the left gets favored you're going to be
like what how can that be i've read
research saying otherwise and i'll say
the exact same thing to you
and then ultimately people are trying to
figure out who's telling the truth and
it's it's damn near impossible so that's
that's a reality
i mean i didn't mention a major flaw
with that study though i mean it is that
is a flaw to know that that was the
point i was making though right so it's
not it's not the point you it's not the
point you wanted it to be but my point
was if a regular person goes on youtube
are they going to be fed in which
direction and the data shows the average
person is fed to the left now if you're
talking about logged in users we need to
know how many of the average person who
watches youtube is logged in it's
actually relatively low
but
there's i think you know what a billion
views per month no no it's more than
that it's like 100 billion or something
like that most people aren't logged in
most people don't log in so it's like
when their cookies or whatever are in
there what are they being recommended if
you want to argue that logging in
changes things for sure let's do
analysis on that maybe there's something
to be seen but what percentage of people
is that relative to the average person
let's move on from this let's talk about
abortion sure because uh we have this
story in the news
well we had the story uh we'll we'll
talk about starbucks and then we'll go
into my my tweet so we can talk about
the meat potatoes here starbucks will
cover travel expenses for employees
abortion and gender change treatments
uh starbucks has announced that they
will be covering eligible travel costs
for employees and their family members
to get abortions or gender change
treatments if the services are not
available within 100 miles of where they
live
quote
in 2018 starbucks broadened its health
insurance options for transgender
partners to not only include gender
assignment surgery
which had been covered since 2013 but
also a host of procedures that were
previously considered cosmetic such as
breast reduction and augmentation
surgery facial feminization hair
transplants and more the company said in
a press release so this is
tesla did the same thing actually tesla
announced that if their employees need
an abortion they'll cover the costs i
think amazon did this as well
but let's talk about um
this is the news story to kick off what
i actually want to get into so forgive
me for the ridiculous segue but uh i
have a tweet here sure i said what
happens if a woman is on the way to get
an abortion at eight months but goes
into labor in the lobby of the abortion
clinic and accidentally delivers the
baby before it could be terminated so
let me explain the back story so why i
tweeted this i was having dinner with a
friend in new york
and they said that they were pro-choice
and i said uh do you agree with
abortion
uh after viability viability of course
is defined as the point at which the
baby can survive on its own
he said uh well no of course not right
but like in the first trimester in the
first several weeks like
it's the mother's decision the
government doesn't have a right and i
said okay okay but you say pro-choice
right
so do you think that if like would you
would you favor the democrats position
and he assumed yes i would i think the
republicans want to ban it and all that
stuff and i was like yeah they do but
the democrats tried passing a bill that
would legal that would legalize in many
states
termination of the baby at up to nine
months up to uh the point of birth in
colorado they've already legalized it
kathy tran in virginia tried uh tried
passing a bill uh ralph northam famously
talked about it so the bill proposed by
democrats that was recently voted down
does include a provision
h.r 3755
that says
in section three paragraph uh i'm sorry
section four
paragraph nine section four of course
starts by saying
uh a patient has a corresponding right
to receive such services without any of
the following limitations or
requirements section nine says a
prohibition on abortion after fetal
viability when in the good faith medical
judgment of the treating health care
provider continuation of the pregnancy
would pose a risk to the pregnant
patient's life or health i showed this
article to my friend and said i have a
question
if the baby is viable why kill it
and he said well you wouldn't and i said
what would you do he's like i
i don't know i said okay and he was like
no maybe they're saying just end the
pregnancy and i was like right right but
that's not induced labor is not abortion
is it
maybe maybe
is that what you're saying because if
you're saying induced labor or c-section
is abortion i think we're in agreement
here you can end the pregnancy but
preserve the life of the baby
the definition of abortion according to
merriam-webster though is the
termination of a pregnancy pers you know
following or directly related uh
relating to
the death of the baby after the fact
so
i don't understand why they would have
to create a law and try to pass it that
would legalize abortion at all if a
woman is eight months pregnant and the
doctor says if you continue this
pregnancy you will die well then they
deliver the baby
they they they have to remove the baby
right
why kill the baby in the process when
you can just remove it can you can you
read that for me one more time
so
the the important first section uh
section of section four uh a general
rule
a health care provider has a statutory
right under this act to provide abortion
services and may provide abortion
services and that provider's patient has
a corresponding right to receive such
services without any of the following
limitations or requirements section 9
reads a prohibition on abortion after
fetal viability when in the good faith
medical judgment of the treating
healthcare provider continuation of the
pregnancy would pose a risk to the
pregnant patient's life or health
sure okay
in terms even says uh in the good faith
what was it the good faith good faith
medical decision of the doctor right if
you're carrying a baby up to eight
months i mean you want that baby
if it's if it's a situation where it's
the mother's health um then i mean they
wanted the baby well so if if the
woman's at eight months pregnant so i
tweeted this right and well that's a
little bit different from what you
tweeted a woman is an eight month
pregnant eight month so i'm saying that
the reason i tweeted that is because if
a woman is at eight months pregnant and
she decides to terminate the pregnancy
aborting the baby you don't you know at
eight months pregnant you don't decide
to terminate you have to terminate
because of medical reasons something's
going on so it's not there's some
decision what are you talking about is
it a woman's decision to terminate the
pregnancy or not i mean if the for her
own health i mean it's between her and
her doctor right but are you saying it's
not her decision what do you
i said if a woman decides to terminate
her pregnancy it's not like she's up and
decided to go i didn't say she up and
decided i'm saying if a woman decides
because of medical issues
okay i mean i think you have to add
because of medical reasons no no because
it's important to be very specific that
people are not carrying a carrying of
you know a uh fetus and you know for
eight months uh and then just going ah i
don't know that's not happening there's
a there's already restrictions that they
have there's already restrictions that
say at that moment you like you know
guys you know about gosnell right
women were getting elective abortions at
nine months
we're talking about what we don't we
don't need to argue edge cases let me go
back to michael so we don't even i want
to make a point here because health of
the mother no no no no no hold on hold
on i'm sorry man i'm sorry man i don't
want to deviate from the point because
we're i have a sincere question based on
the law
an abortion is is legally defined as
terminating a pregnancy of or relating
to the end of the ending the baby's life
the baby dies in the process right
if they if if this if if you're saying
okay well abortions also happen when you
know the baby has already died there's
been a miscarriage of course yeah right
so so let me this i read you the law
it would legalize a woman
for for uh the reasons of of health and
good faith
to terminate the baby
up to nine months because of its
viability viabilities extends from 21
weeks until the point of birth
so this bill would allow it would
actually legalize in many states a baby
just before birth being killed
like aborted right
for medical reasons if there's
no reason well if a mother's life is in
danger or if there's something wrong
with something something something's
wrong with the the fetus well i'm not so
talking about the life of the patient's
life and we're not talking about the
fetus something wrong with the fetus i i
get it like the baby's already dead the
baby's already dead right here's my
question no one's carrying a baby for
eight months and then has to go that's
not an argument if the doctor
is saying no one does a thing is not
real because some people did and some
people don't and we're not talking about
we're talking about the law the law says
if a woman is pregnant and for any
reason do you believe that for any
reason a woman has a right to terminate
her pregnancy me personally yes i
believe it's a woman's body
what's that
so you think a woman who's pregnant with
a baby at nine months she can say
snip its neck i mean we have laws that
basically say they can't just up snip
and snack i mean that's a really weird
way to push do you think so do you know
how they perform abortions on late term
yes where they send the the forceps in
and cut the spinal column
you think that's okay for a baby who's
eight and eight eight eight eight months
and two weeks in a woman's but they're
not doing no one is just selectively
doing that you just said you're not
gonna talk about edge cases and then
you're going around talking about edge
cases you're you used i mean when you
said no one does does that i'm going to
give you an example of it happening i'm
not trying to argue that you are so the
issue is i'm not talking about i'm not
talking should it be legal you said yes
right
here's my question let me let me ask you
the question and please if the woman is
told by a doctor if you continue with
the pregnancy you will die
right should they kill the baby
at eight months yes if they if the
mother is told that she will die and
there's no way at eight months we're
talking eight months this woman wants
the birth the spirit wants the baby
they'll
they'll do whatever they can to save the
baby that's not the law says the law
allows for the termination of the baby
it says the good faith it says the
doctors uh you know and the doctor i'm
not arguing the woman's not sick if a
woman is sick at eight months the baby
is viable it says after fetal viability
and the doctor says if you continue with
the pregnancy your health is at risk
do you believe it should be legal at
that point to kill the baby but that's
not happening you're talking
i'm saying yes or no do you think it
should be legal they're trying to
legalize it doesn't matter if it's
happening they're trying to legalize it
yes or no they're trying to legalize the
fact that women at eight months pregnant
could find out something is horribly
wrong with the fetus where it will die
as soon as it's born be in pain have
cancer the question or not i'm answering
the question no no no no no because
you're saying something i agree with you
on and no one disagrees with you on
everyone wants to preserve the health of
the mother sure why kill the baby in the
process they're not killing the baby in
the process why legalize the killing of
the baby they're not legalizing yes they
are read the law i read it to you how
many times after fetal viability the
baby can survive on its own they can
perform an abortion if the mother's
health is at risk why kill the baby why
not include in that all efforts must be
made to save the baby's life it's right
there when it says the
the exact wording i don't have in front
of me because i have my the dot what the
doctor said the good faith efforts of
the doctor the doctors looking out for
both the patient not the baby abortion
is the termination of the baby if it
wasn't about legalizing the killing of
the baby they would say perform a
c-section or induce labor when they're
with what this is right here it says
they cannot prohibit abortion late-term
abortion is a practice with legal
definitions where the baby is killed its
limbs are removed and it's sucked out
if the mother if the baby is viable why
not just induce labor or perform a
c-section in fact when hassan quoted my
tweet that's what his followers said
apparently they disagree with you i mean
if they can do that they would do that
at eight months for sure then why
legalize
why i just explained to you because it
needs to happen sometimes
for the health of the mother or for the
the child killing the baby yes it needs
to happen if there's something terribly
horribly wrong with a child would you
agree that and immediately die or be in
horrible pain for hours before dying
anyway would you agree with a provision
added to this bill saying all efforts
must be made to preserve the life of any
baby after viability i mean you're
asking for exactly what's there but if
that makes you happy then i mean sure
why not that's but that's not what's
there
so so so we agree we completely agree
100
i mean except for you saying a woman
should decide on light term abortion i
don't agree with that okay but so so we
agree this bill should have an extended
provision to protect the life of i mean
i think it's there i think it's there
that's my opinion i think it says it
right there which which part do you
think says it must
preserve the life we've already went
over this 100 times it says right in the
you think the doctor is not looking out
for both the mother and the child they
are i think oftentimes the doctor's
looking out they're not even they're not
really looking out for either i think in
many cases they're trying to make money
so
that's partial marshall i have numbers
for you i have numbers for you partial
birth abortionist john mcmahon says the
primary reason given for those
requesting a late term abortion is
depression uh the guttmacher institute
which is a pro-choice think tank said
that they surveyed women obtaining
late-term abortions they found that only
about one percent of second and third
trimester abortions are performed for
fetal anomalies
which is another way of saying like
eugenics there's a disability so we kill
them one third of the women said that
they misjudged how far along they were
one fourth said they found it hard to
arrange an earlier abortion 14
that they were afraid to tell their
parents or their partner and the rest
gave reasons such as taking their time
to decide or waiting for a change in
their relationships i will also add the
cdc divides abortion as a termination of
a pregnancy that does not result in live
birth
so my question is why do the democrats
try to legalize the killing of a viable
baby without any protections
i mean i don't know i mean i'm telling
you right there it says right there
exactly but you're in favor of late term
abortion i think it's up to a mother a
woman and her doctor
so i actually agree with uh the initial
roe v wade uh
i i guess you i mean have you read roe v
wade of course yeah so you know about
the limitations on the trimester yeah so
so you know about the limitations of
course yes but so do you agree with that
what do you mean that's the law of the
land for now
so so you actually you just told me that
you think a woman should be able to
choose to terminate the baby no i did i
said
the decision of what happens to a
pregnant woman is up to her and her
doctor that's all i'm telling you let me
ask you a question if there was a baby
on a table and someone grabbed a pair of
you know bolt cutters and put it to its
neck would you stop them
you're talking about a live person right
i'm talking about a baby right just born
right on the spot right that's that's a
person what if the baby was coming out
of the woman and then they snip its neck
but no one's doing that guys gus nell
did it don't don't say don't give me an
absolute and then tell me not to make an
edge point don't say no one did it when
someone did it the point is i'm asking
you moral questions on where your
position is so i can understand why you
would support these positions because i
don't understand
so if the baby was delivered you're
saying it can't be killed
now do you understand my tweet
if the woman was intending to abort the
baby at eight months
and went into an early labor while she
was going to the abortion clinic and the
baby was born right there in the lobby
could she not kill it now
well if she had the baby as she was
going to get her eight month abortion
there's something horribly wrong with
that baby i hope it's not in pain
because they were just going to answer
the question i just i'm going talking
about it i said
can
okay oh can she if the baby is born no
because that's a person so what if so
now let's move backwards the baby is a
person the moment it's born right
is that what you're saying yes what if
the baby is halfway out
halfway up like so do you know they do
late term abortions at the point of
birth
partial birth abortions the baby is
coming out and they kill it as it comes
out okay
that's literally what they do
bro
i believe women have the right to choose
within the first trimester and partly
into the second trimester
because the government can't mandate
someone else gave their body to someone
else the challenge i have
as a traditional liberal and social
liberal is when you start introducing
the rights of secondary persons to the
equation like roe v wade actually stated
the privacy rights of the baby enter at
the point of viability these questions
are difficult to answer so my position
has always been safe legal rare first
trimester discretion of the woman even
though i really don't like the idea of
abortion as contraception so you like
you like where it is right now
that's a hard thing to say considering
all the states have difficulties no i
think it's a very easy thing to say
because you said it's safe legal and
rare right which states
i don't like where it's not because
colorado legalized nine-month partial
birth abortion kathy tran in virginia
tried doing the same i don't know where
they went on that and ralph northam
actually said the baby would be
delivered and then they would decide
they have a discussion that's not what
he said he was talking he said they
would have discussed he was talking
about if there's context right before
where he said that if there was
something horribly wrong with the baby
like the baby's born in a vegetative
state and he's not going to live a life
that you know it's not i don't say that
i didn't say that he didn't say that he
said but you didn't you didn't say that
he did either
so for one we've played the video
multiple times what he said was this
typically so he's asked by the presenter
kathy tran presented a bill that would
legalize abortion up to the point of
birth he said typically this happens in
instances of severe disability or
deformity and i will tell you what would
happen the baby would be delivered it
would be resuscitated if that's what
they decided it would be made
comfortable
and then a discussion would happen
so my my issue there is i i disagree i
mean if it's if a baby is alive
i think every effort must be made to try
and save its life i think if a homeless
person is bleeding and they fall onto
the stairs of a hospital the hospital
absolutely must save that person's life
the same thing as a baby that's born
with deformities or otherwise i don't
think you can see a person and be like
they're dying we should kill them
whether it's a baby or otherwise so the
issue here is
i'm pro-choice what was your what was
your feelings on the terry chavo case
i don't have strong opinions on that one
i mean for one
you don't you don't you don't you just
don't care well i just say i don't care
all right it's a difficult moral
question i don't know the answers to
okay so first who did you think who did
you more to lean towards there i'd
probably say we would lean towards
preserving the life of terry chavo even
though that's not what she wanted
well if that was the case i don't i
don't know enough about it if she signed
uh do not resist it no she literally she
told her husband that she did not want
to be left in a vegetative state then
that's her right with saying a dnr
absolutely this was according to her
husband and there's no formal paperwork
and her parents said we will take care
of it then you can't do it yeah if she
had a dnr i i respect the dnr it's her
life it's her choice uh without illegal
without illegal do not resuscitate then
you have to defer the next if can as for
the husband would be that well right i
mean i'm not the boss of people i'm not
the i'm not the king no no no no no no
no no because we just we just the the
the the thing that james just said and
then you agreed with was that um if she
is in a vegetative state
and the husband says
that i was told by her that that's it
and then he brought up how there's no
proof of that the parents wanted her
alive they said they would take care of
her
they're not the next kind though the
husband is the husband has the ultimate
decision of her what of her care right
yes i agree that's not i'm well i'm
adding the context because he said if
she signed paperwork and so i'm i'm
pointing out that that wasn't the
situation okay yeah all right just
making sure just being conscious and
clear here so social liberals is a
reference to it so wait do you so do you
think that you know in the case of a
child's health
that you know and they are not adult so
they can't make decisions for themselves
do you think the parent can make that
decision for a child's health
yes absolutely okay so if a baby is born
in a vegetative state
can the parent decide to put it out of
its misery and not let it just die a
slow agonizing death and say i am the
next of kin
this is not how this life should be
we should just end that life and life
support no
you don't think that's about the baby
wasn't involved in a traumatic injury
right so there's there's there's
questions they were they were they were
they were born with a a life-altering
could not even probably won't perhaps
won't live yeah and you're saying it's
okay for them to be in a vegetative
state for who knows how long uh they
likely will die in a few months maybe
maybe even make it a year just in in the
hospital yeah you're saying that
anything you want to i i think there's a
difference between someone who suffered
so you don't think you don't think
parents have you don't think that
parents have the right to do what's best
for their children well that's this
thing she said that can i you just said
that no let's just say that baby isn't
the best for the baby yes that is it's a
parent's decision if the baby is in a
vegetative state and will never have any
quality of life
the humane caring loving thing for a
parent
arguing edge cases what are you talking
about
now who's arguing no because you brought
up the ralph i know my answer the answer
is you brought up the ralph northam
thing i gave you the answer so you don't
think that clearly don't agree with the
idea that a baby is born with deformity
you kill it i clearly told me just
talking about
we're not talking about with like a limp
arm or something we're talking about a
quality of life disability where they
will never be able to have any quality
of life
i can i can say the same thing over and
over again i believe that we should not
allow doctors to kill a baby regardless
uh i think every effort should be made
to preserve the life of the baby okay so
you don't think that people should have
a right to die with dignity at all
basically
kathy newman we're not talking about
that
if a woman i think that's i think it all
i think it all really if it wasn't like
terry suffers a stroke a disease
she's older and later in life and she
has the ability to make a cognitive
decision or her next of kin does and
it's the issue of do we pull her off
life support that's different from a
newborn baby in a different way
the legal context is the parents have
the full right to do what's best for
their child i think this is a
conservative position too by the way in
terms of parents having anything i got
to tell you i'm a liberal okay
so let me make a point okay
the the the the issue uh well go ahead
go ahead well because we have to
distinguish between two things there are
situations where a person is
injured to the point where they require
extraordinary measures in in in order to
stay alive so we're not talking about
you know food water basic treatment
we're talking about things like being
hooked up to an insane amount of
machines uh things that are incredibly
burdensome there is a difference between
a person in that situation who's saying
without all of these unnatural means i
would die so pull the plug and saying
this person's alive but they're
suffering so we're going to kill them
there's a difference between pulling the
plug in a life support situation where
that person requires extraordinary means
to stay alive and a person who is alive
and is sustained but you're deciding to
go out of your way to kill them those
are two different situations yeah that's
a good point but he's but also i think
the point you're making too is if the
baby was in a situation where was dying
let's say the baby's born with a hole in
its heart which happens and it's
bleeding too fast for them to to try and
surgically repair my answer is we'll
repair it let's say baby's both without
a brain it's happened before yeah uh
i i do not i think the issue is i'll
tell you why i i take the pro-choice
stance the traditional liberal one not
the modern liberal one
i don't believe the government has a
right to dictate a person give their
body or blood to another person and
there are questions of privacy and there
are questions of government overreach
however when it's when another person
enters the equation you have one person
sharing two bodies that's why i'm like
you know so so second third trimester
abortions are where things get get risky
now when it comes to
a baby being born the question is the
legal permission to kill a baby i say
the answer is no every effort must be
made to save the life of the baby the in
the instance of terry chavo every effort
was made to save her but she was
dwindling they so so it's a question
what is the effort to save the life of a
baby bomb without a brain
actually none so the the baby that was
born without a brain just the the who is
what the cerebellum i think i don't know
if you know the story the
involuntary functions all functioned
completely fine and uh general stimuli
happened so the baby was able to eat was
able to you know basically live and grow
but uh not you know articulate thoughts
or learn math or things like that the
the the bigger issue is not a singular
case right the issue i have with the
terry shavo case is the legal
protections of the individual
terry shaw in this instance has had an
opportunity to file a dnr or not without
a do not resuscitate it falls to the
next of kin a baby hasn't had that
opportunity we don't know so we just say
preserve the life to the best of our
abilities there are many circumstances
where babies were born
in a state that a doctor has said it's
not viable and the baby's actually lived
there are many people who uh actually
survived attempts at abortion there are
many people who were born and the doctor
didn't believe it was possible there are
many people who were born with a doctor
said you will die if you have this baby
in fact a good friend of mine was
bedridden i think the entirety of her
pregnancy because the doctor said we
have no choice and she said i will lie
still on a bed for nine months to have
this baby and the doctor was like you
can't do it and she had the baby and the
kids healthy and alive and living and
she made that choice
absolutely so that everyone can stay in
a bed for nine months straight that's
amazing so my issue is if only this
country did this did something for
mothers they could all be in that same
position so the reason i disagree with
late term abortion especially i mean
partial birth abortion is out of the
question is that when a secondary
individual's rights are brought into
question you don't have an easy way to
say one person's rights trump trump
another in which case i think later
abortions are wrong i think the killing
of a baby the terminating of a pregnancy
as the cdc defines it as the democrats
proposed it would be wrong and for some
reason
sheamus over here who's pro-life who
disagrees with the uh lydia who
disagrees with my position
have them have a much more reasonable
position to where i'm at than the left
does so for me let me explain it social
liberal my whole life i believe there
were there should have been efforts to
alleviate inequality among marginalized
races growing up in chicago and
experiencing it and i believed that
freedom of speech was very very
important and we must protect the civil
rights of all people and you know my
family typically was in the position of
first trimester it's begrudgingly okay
we don't like it but we recognize the
extent to which we're willing government
uh to allow to have a say in certain
matters when it comes to a person's life
but when it comes to the issue of a
viable baby then killing it would be
egregious and wrong now that position
doesn't exist among the modern left in
terms of the political space i can talk
to a democrat like my friend who will
tell me that's their belief and i'll say
but that's not what the democrats are
trying to pass according to the cdc
abortion would end the life of the baby
and the democrats passed a bill that had
a blanket open the life of the baby can
be ended if the mother's health is in
question but if the mother's health is
in question it doesn't explain why you
would end the life of the baby when you
could just induce labor or assist
perform a c-section and that's what
happens when that situation is that's
not an abortion
wait what what let me let me start again
the cdc defines abortion as
a
a procedure intended to terminate a
suspected or known ongoing intra
intrauterine pregnancy imprints in the
wrong and that does not result in a live
birth the democrats bill
would
remove any restriction on abortion that
is
ending a pregnancy with no live birth
after viability
if the pregnancy uh if the pregnant
patient's life isn't is in jeopardy so
where where are you i'm i'm i'm a little
bit the reason i think there's some
confusion here so i'm confused what your
position is what is the timpool position
on this because you said safe legal and
rare well i i've absolutely defined it
several times let me do it again for you
okay within the first trimester do you
think it's not safe legal and rare now
i don't know what that means what does
that mean i don't know that's what
you've been saying that it needs to be
safe legal and rare so what are you so
where are you so what do you consider
what do you consider to be safe legal
and rare descrip without bringing up
anything in other states give me what
you consider a safe abortion a legal
abortion and a and what rare means in
the term of abortion so safe legal and
rare is a political uh catch phrase from
that you use a lot yes right right
because it represents the position of
we don't like abortion we think it's
wrong
right so but it's not it's not wrong yes
it is it's not wrong traditional
liberals if if abortion saves a woman's
life then it's not wrong it's a medical
but it's a it's a triumph of medicine a
woman's life i'm sorry
let me try and answer so uh in the 90s
we said safe illegal and rare because it
represented a position we had abortion
as contraception is wrong what do you
think do you think abortion as
contraception is okay
abortion is contraception like well
that's why we need to have sex education
because it's it's preferable to not do
that i don't disagree do you think
abortion is contraception is wrong i
personally i wouldn't do it because i
mean i have two kids so i mean i've
planned and you know these were two
planned children um and these are two
kids that i wanted to have but is it
wrong is it wrong what abortion is
contraception no i don't think it's
wrong it's not a perp in a perfect world
we would have sex education and this
wouldn't and wouldn't happen but we
don't live in a perfect world well
so why why would a perfect world i'm
confused are you saying it's wrong or
it's not wrong well it's not wrong so so
we don't need sex education it's fine no
sex education is preferable i just said
that right right but you're but it
irrespective of abortion as
contraception because you don't think
it's wrong i don't think it's wrong but
it's preferable that it doesn't happen
okay okay okay i understand i understand
so uh i think it's wrong
um but i don't think it should uh i just
i don't like the idea that the
government intervenes to at a certain
stage in the pregnancy and so i still
haven't answered my question about what
what's safe legal and rare means to you
to you like what is what is what does
rare for you mean in the sense of
abortion not abortionist contraception
okay which is 92 percent of abortions
elective abortions okay we have we have
in terms of what percentage is is rape
or incest i think it's like one percent
i think right right right right it's
less than it's like 0.4
so rare is
people should not be
going out having sex getting pregnant
and then being like get an abortion
however
my position
because it comes from a libertarian
stance the government shouldn't be
involved means
it's going to happen i don't like it i
think it's wrong but safe legal and rare
means legal means the government doesn't
intervene however i mean by the way
but by the sense of it being legal the
government has intervened
because they've made it legal no the
government doesn't make things legal
things are either illegal or or
things that already are legal or they're
decriminalized or they're made illegal
if the government doesn't make something
legal for you if if if roe v wade gets
overturned
what happens in this country
abortion becomes up to the states who
can make it illegal right but they're
right but states can already
remove the restrictions in place
okay so you said they're making it legal
they can they can they can they can they
can remove some restrictions so so to
answer your question as i've been trying
to you know you know we don't we don't
go by the the trimester thing anymore
right what do you mean
roe v wade isn't the law though roe v
wade is the law of when it comes to
abortion but we don't go by first second
and third trimester when it comes right
right right right those are those are
just easy ways to understand what i
really mean no no no no no because it's
not that's not accurate at all it's not
just an easy way to understand
you know what kcv planned parenthood is
right yes what is it
it's the 1992 provision that set the
remove the restrictions on on trimester
and raise the question of viability i
don't know what you're asking okay and
it also
paved the way for
more i don't know the point you're
trying to make restrictions right okay
so we already allowed in this country
dude thanks to roe v wade and kcb
planned parenthood we can a uh a state
can decide
to put restrictions on abortion
even in the first trimester now uh-huh
since 1992 casey right right and after
viability which is different for every
woman it's up to a doctor to decide when
through scanning and everything
they can then say
oh once it's viable
the state can ban abortion completely at
that point
except for in the case of health of the
mother
right and which makes no sense how does
that make no sense why kill a baby if
it's viable no no no no no you don't
understand yeah they can ban abortion
except for
when it needs to happen to protect the
life and safety and health of the mother
i mean we already know we already see
the baby is viable
and the pregnancy needs to be ended
why
kill the baby we're talking we're
talking at like
could be like 20 weeks
right viability specifically at 20 weeks
and the baby's not viable that's why i
don't care for the trimester i think my
point is if the baby is viable life
rights come into play
so for conservatives and pro-lifers life
rights are in play from the day of
conception uh well you're looking at
this like you're arguing with a
pro-choice
person because you're telling me you
realize that like what when when should
when do you think abortion should should
uh you know be
legal like when when should they be ban
on abortion like what liability because
at that point the baby can just be
delivered that's not true all the time
though right if so that's why i said it
should be all attempts to save the life
of the baby shall be made if the baby
dies because it can't survive well you
know that's that's that's that's
difficult if the health of the mother is
at risk and they make an attempt to save
the
six months the baby's barely viable
the mother is told
you you're at risk for this this
condition and we have to end the
pregnancy i'm sorry
every effort should be made to save the
life of the baby that but the baby might
die and i recognize that it's
unfortunate and i think that should be
allowed the abortion should happen uh
i'm sorry the abortion is legally
defined shouldn't a a induced delivery
via so what is your name so what is your
opinion about what's because we're
talking about this now and you know i
think obviously we have our opinions and
we're agreeing on some things and
disagreeing on others um what is what is
your opinion on what's going on right
now though like that's colorado removed
all restrictions no i'm talking about
what's going to happen right now with
the supreme court yeah they're going to
overturn roe v wade okay red states are
going to enact trigger laws and they're
going to outright ban abortion across
the board yes right i disagree with that
okay good i i think especially when the
conservatives argue uh uh rape and
incest it seems to be a conflicted
argument where they say
uh in the instance of rape and incest
will allow that exception and i'm like i
can understand that point from a
libertarian perspective but not from a
moral position on when life begins
because i mean sheamus no exceptions
yeah there's a couple things i want to
jump into here so you mentioned
situations where a mother has to have an
abortion because her life is at risk and
there are doctors i've spoken to there
are even notes and petitions signed by
literal hundreds of doctors who say
that is a that is an inaccurate
description that is not what happens
there is no such thing as a medically
necessary abortion there are procedures
that might need to be performed on a
woman who is pregnant which can cause
her to miscarry but that is not the same
as an abortion abortion is when you go
in there with the direct intent
to end the life of an unborn child if
there's an operation
that has to be performed in order to
save the life of the mother but it poses
a risk to the unborn child and increases
the probability that they will die that
there will be a miscarriage
that is not an abortion that is an
attempt at a medical procedure that has
an unintended consequence that is the
cdc's definition of abortion yeah so
if that i think that's important because
when i tweeted that thing about abortion
eight months hassan's followers said
you're an idiot it they would they would
perform a c-section or induce labor but
the cdc doesn't define induced labor or
second as that it says not resulting in
a live birth um what i'm confused about
here and we could talk about this
because i feel like we've already
covered this so i'm sure if you want to
just go over and offload but but what
i'm what i'm concerned about here in
terms of like um talking with you about
this is you know for the past couple of
weeks i've noticed you've been talking a
lot about this issue and it's been a big
issue since roe v wade but your focus
seems to have been on these sort of edge
cases that bolster the
anti-choice position like you're not
here sitting here and talking about how
horrible it is about all the women who
will miscarry and go through all sorts
of the legal issues in these red states
you're not sitting here talking about um
you know how hard that is for people not
everyone is
no it's not just yeah yeah yeah that's a
major factor in people i know it's hard
yeah but you've also not heard me say
apparently that when i tell
conservatives if you want to live in
these areas where your kids are in these
schools you need to get up and move and
it might be hard i mean my position
what do schools have to do what we're
talking about right now like we're
talking about we're talking to
when you're like why aren't you why
aren't you telling women to send others
i say the same thing to conservatives
like my position on
personal responsibility is the same
across the board regardless of what the
issue is
no it's not it's not because you're phil
you've been focusing on the past past
two weeks or three weeks however long
it's been you've been focusing on
talking about these edge case scenarios
where like oh you bring up ralph northam
he's not even relevant anymore that law
this is three years ago now he's not
even in kathy tran what to me is kathy
trans maybe she is i don't know but that
bill is not up for anything it would be
it would be
so they're trying to pass these bills
that i don't like right well they're not
going to be able to
is so is it is it because maybe i spoke
up against it and helped contributed to
pushback from people who disagree with
it is that true did you do that
considering that i've been speaking
about that issue for a long enough
period of time and we live next to
loudoun county and people in virginia
are fans of the show and i see them i
think we did i think the fact that i
said these psychopaths are trying to
pass a bill where the woman actually
said at the point of birth you could
kill the baby i think that absolutely
contributes to people being like voter
out get her out now i don't know if
she's still in office but northland for
sure the ralph northam thing absolutely
matt walsh came down here 20 minutes
away sure okay i mean that's why i told
you temple's got power because because
why aren't you using why aren't using
the same power to fight what we're
talking about right now
fight what
what's going to happen to a pro uh
women's i will not stand next to a man
who told me to my face he is okay with
killing a baby at nine months
if i had to make the choice between
banning abortion across the board or
standing next to people who would
advocate for nine-month abortion i will
stand next to the people who are saying
ban it across the board period okay you
need to understand how psychotic i'm
glad
the record in colorado sounds when they
say
terminate the life of the baby at
viability to to the overwhelming
majority of this country that think
that's wrong but 70 of this country is
pro-choice and believes there should be
restrictions and there are right now you
should be advocating right now dorado
you should be advocating right now for
exactly what we have right so to
disagree with roe v wade i don't
disagree with it
but you do because what capacity because
how does how does colorado well how is
colorado allowed to have those
restrictions under roe v wade no i'll
i'll agree with you to us i mean you
have to no you have to if colorado agree
with you you just got super angry at me
now i'm doing the same too and i got to
slow down if you i made one point you
make i'm trying to address one point
okay do i say one thing you said
you said i would i would i would
actually say
i would probably lean at this point more
towards uh rights falling to the
individual states
so you okay so you're happy you're
overweight is is down i wouldn't say
happy that's that's a bit of an
overstatement i mean i think but i but i
mean you are now on the record saying
you prefer roe v wade not being the law
of the land
i think that's uh i think the issue is
more so i mean i mean it's a pretty
simple i think this is a easy
talking i want you to answer it
definitively right so uh i'm a moderate
right i have i thought you're a liberal
moderates can be liberals um okay yeah
so social liberal is a center-left
position on the political compass that's
typically where i've been my whole life
uh there are deep moral and ethical
questions i don't have the answers to
at this point considering the disruption
in the united states and the extreme
hyperpolarization i would i would fall
more towards on states rights and that's
because that's not that's not a liberal
position at all
i mean states rights is is firmly in
right-wing libertarianism it's not
right-wing libertarian it's actually
just general libertarian so left
libertarians also agree with with
decentralization of authority and power
libertarians do not agree with
the decentralization of authority and
power not in that same way but
anarchists want a strong federal
government anarchists and libertarians
are not the same left libertarians and
and comes you think they want a strong
federal government
no arc anarchists and libertarians not
the same thing do you know
do you know what the political compass
is yes i do you know what anarchy means
yes what does anarchy mean anarchy means
the absence of government no government
anarchy means without authority yeah so
you if you're an authoritarian you
adhere to that's the same thing what i
just said no authority
so you can be you can be a left
libertarian or a right libertarian
uh liberty civil liberties are still on
civil liberties yes so if you're a left
libertarian you typically agree with but
left libertarians agree in civil
liberties across the board they don't
want like one state saying uh civil
liberties these civil liberties okay but
another state is saying the civil
liberties are not okay if the state
enforces something as authoritarian
not necessarily i'm not saying it's
authoritarianism i'm saying it's an
authoritarian position oh it comes from
the position of power and authority
right right right so left libertarian
depending on which position you're at
would advocate for different but
okay
if you want to have the political
composition uh conversation we could do
that but i want to go back to what we're
just talking about uh you know because i
don't think you definitively said on the
record
what is your position on roe v wade do
you prefer it for it for it yeah my
issue outside of roe v your show's being
ripped apart no no but you just said
prevent comments you just you just said
before that you'd prefer it not to
happen because you hated what was
happening in colorado and no that's not
what i said that is what you said
i wish we could rewind this people will
be able to rewind this that's what you
said calm down
colorado is the extreme left position
if i were to say the states can make
their decision colorado is allowed to
keep doing what they're doing that's not
restricting it if i were to say the
federal government
should step in it would stop colorado
from doing it my position on roe v wade
for the most part is that i agree with
it my position on today's politics
across the board is that the country is
being gutted and ripped apart and
perhaps preventing conflict means
pulling back on what states can do
weakening the federal government okay i
mean that's not a position on abortion
it's a position on authority versus
liberty it means bad things will happen
i don't like but it also means i'm
worried that the extreme polarization of
colorado or virginia versus oklahoma are
deeply troubling
and maybe pulling back federal authority
can help
alleviate some of the tension i'm not
saying it's a def it's a guaranteed
answer i don't know it's right
but my position on authority versus
liberty is irrespective of abortion my
position on authority and liberty means
bad things happen i don't like but i'm
trying to stop people from killing each
other
if you have a total ban on abortion the
left goes nuts if you have unrestricted
abortion the right goes nuts i'm
actually what we have right now stephen
you know you talk about compromise right
i've heard you talk about compromise
what we have right now is
would be your perfect scenario right
it's not because
in many states they were moving all the
restrictions and the democrats at the
federal level just tried to allow the
termination of a baby at nine months
if they add a provision to it that says
all efforts must be made to save the
life of a baby and took out the term
abortion and said a pregnancy case but
that that that didn't but that didn't
pass you have to worry about it
they just tried to pass it and it didn't
pass do you know where i live sure west
virginia i'm here right now do you know
who my senator is uh
joe manchin and who stopped the bill
from passing there you go and why do you
think i'm talking about it because
you're a big fan of joe manchin because
joe manchin did something i like i don't
like joe manchin for the most
part him
i think he's an establishment chill i
think he just says what he thinks is
gonna he's gonna play the the best and i
don't think i don't think he's genuinely
interested in fixing problems what did
you think about him killing build back
better
define you mean the the infrastructure
plan no the bill that the the bill that
had a swath of things the main thing for
me the main thing that would have really
been amazing is the child care the um
the uh return of the child tax credits
the uh extension of um of um uh what is
it the uh 3k uh
federally i mean those are those are
huge amazing things if you're you know
if you're a fan of um you know uh doing
the best for children in this country
those things were fantastic so
in 2008
into 2012 into 2016 i've always been in
favor of social programs and i've always
advocated for such my concern with them
is that what happens with a lot of these
social programs is let's say you get a
wound on your arm is my my analogy uh
people are homeless kids don't have food
your society has a wound so we put a
bandage on it that's a government
program we're trying to mend that damage
the problem with the government is that
12 months later instead of taking the
bandage off and assessing the issue sun
setting or otherwise they reapply
another bandage on top instead of using
this weird anecdote can you give me an
actual example they never they never
reassess or end programs
so when programs like what program do
you think should be ended
i'm not saying they should i don't know
but that's what you just said so what
i'm saying is that you said they should
reassess programs and end them that's
what you just said i know you're smiling
but you're not understanding what i'm
saying okay okay
physical corporations private
corporations
can fail right of course
social programs can't
when have we
or or uh has there been a major
reassessment of programs that have or
have not worked
so i'll give you an example you can look
at the disaster that was pruitt i go
right so i did a documentary on the
public housing and how instead of
reassessing and solving the problem it
dissolved into racist
violence and created some of the most
worst racial tensions in this country in
in st louis
my issue with government programs is
that they're good but we need to make
sure we have strong leadership and we
don't just say sign the check sign the
check sign the check sign the check
my issue right now what did you think of
the child tax credit
uh explain uh give me the details sure
children parents of children under the
age of i think it was six
would get three hundred dollars a month
tax credit and then um
over six and two i believe i don't
remember when the cutoff was i know
specifically six and two-year-olds
because that's the age of my children um
and so every month i was able to receive
along with everybody else who has a
child in that age range um 300 for the
under six
200 uh 250 for the oh the six-year-old
and for me personally like people might
be shocked to know this if they know me
as a blue check on twitter but um just
having you know a blue check on twitter
doesn't mean you're all that rich or
wealthy good thing yeah yeah um two
points though two points
let me explain child tax credit so
basically they get uh you know you get
that child tax but for me for my family
it's a huge shock we would pay for a
number of child care things
schooling as well um go ahead two points
one uh child tax credits are incredible
and really good things
we if there's anything we want to do in
this country is provide tax breaks to
parents and do what we can to encourage
people to have families second point is
my criticism of
buildback better for the most part was
the economy is imploding
so my my perspective on a lot of these
things has less to do with what a
perfect society can and should do and
and more so like have you looked at the
m1 money stock recently no let me pull
that up for you
well one thing while you're doing that
you said before that um you know you had
you you believed you had some power
based on where you are in terms of local
politics well i'm talking about as a
resident of west virginia my advocacy
plays a role in short people in west
virginia well while you're on air right
now you should tell joe manchin that um
the child tax credit was a huge help to
families across this
country manchester child tax credit was
a huge help
across this country i'm really happy
you're doing that so and you should
advocate for it more often on your show
it really it really is we literally have
good we i hold up but you realize it's
like that's a that's also a deeply
far-right position i'm not saying it's
it's only a fire edition if you look at
i think romania they do huge tax credits
when you have kids
like it is like conservatives are like
more babies more babies government
government tax credits take a look at
the m1 money stock it's weird though
that that's the case in romania because
here in this country every republican
voted against it but it's not but it's
not just voting against that take a look
at the m1 money stock do you want us do
you know what this is what this is what
it represents honestly i'm not familiar
with this does this look shocking this
spike sure does it look shocking
compared to going back to 1960 in terms
of our money supply
sure something weird is going on and if
you look beyond the major spike
this is the uh m1 money supply
it's a it's a reference to money and
circulation in uh 2020 because of the
pandemic
the rules were changed that allowed
savings accounts to enter general money
supply used to be that there were
limitations on how much you could pull
out of savings this caused a massive
spike in the money supply from 4
trillion up to 16 trillion
eligible in the money supply but we can
ignore that because it's a rule change
although i think it's substantial you
take a look at from may of 2020 until
today and you can see that the economy
has expanded or i should say that the
money supply is expanded by over four
trillion dollars
one of the reasons if not the biggest
reason why we're seeing such rapid
inflation which is gutting families is
because of the mass spending i'd love to
see a tax credit for families
based on kids i'd love to see people get
huge benefits when they have kids and i
think it's one of the best ways to
actually dish out tax credits sure and i
just want to also add again that um
republicans vote against those things
all the time the right ones were against
that i want to make no money that clear
like we should really yeah i don't want
republicans good yeah good so when you
look at the money supply and you realize
that we are headed towards a credit
cardiac arrest stealing that line from
uh hugo ferranto and juice rap news
we can't we can't sustain this
we we are in we are in dire straits
right here uh diesel fuel is is facing
shortages you know what happens if
diesel shortages hit oh sure it's harder
for trucks to deliver you know no no
that means they can't grow food okay
what are you gonna eat okay only after
every every trucker has run out of gas
after every factory has stopped
producing and every farm stopped so what
do you think socialists realize you
can't eat money what do you think we
should do about it i think we got to
curtail the spending and raise interest
rates okay one of the things they did
was you don't think we should raise
taxes on on who people under the wealthy
who's the wealthy i mean who's the
wealthy no no like like right
i'll say uh you know for me wealthy is
probably much lower than most based on
my own how much do welcome people paying
taxes but um
not enough what not enough tell me how
much you want to tax not enough what's
the number not enough probably what
we've taxed them back in uh you know in
the fdr years what is that probably like
something like 90 something but they
didn't pay that in the fdr years they
skirted that well that's part of why
they adjusted the tax code right so so
90 of what
of their
their their tax i mean of their uh
income
how do rich people make money i mean how
do rich people make it how do people
make money there's all sorts of
different ways they make money some of
them invest you know what jeff bezos is
income is
oh you're talking about because they
have so much in stocks no
okay then what are you talking about
what you said their income
right what's jeff bezos's income oh i
don't know if he's cashed any stocks
this year i don't know what his regular
income is i don't know 83 his uh his his
income his salary income is 83 000 right
his actual income doesn't surprise me
they do sure make a million bucks sure
he makes a million dollars sure that's
how much he makes sure you want to tax a
guy who makes a million dollars uh yeah
for sure is that gonna pay down four
trillion dollars in in in are you saying
are you saying that uh someone like that
is never going to cash in any of their
stock they don't he just lives off a
million dollars a year they do i
actually think we should tax the rich by
the way i just think you don't know
anything about it i simply want to tax
them more it's that simple but where i
mean where like text them on what oh uh
capital gains how much um i just told
you what 90 of capital gains yeah what
will that do well i do bring them a lot
of money why i mean why why would i
bring a lot of money
what does that mean why did we why would
that bring in a lot of money i'm telling
you how would taxing someone's capital
gains bring in money give me the give me
the give me the mechanics
if someone sells for example elon musk
sells a billion dollars in tesla stock
and we take
900 million of it
so if he doesn't he still has a hundred
million if he doesn't if he doesn't sell
the stock what happens well sure then
that happens yeah so then you're not
taxing anything well they do need to
they do sell they do i mean he just did
though right yeah and then he paid the
more taxes than anyone else in history i
i think we should we should tax the rich
right in a uh a variety of ways oh did
youtube just crash
we just lost every super chat are you
kidding me
you know what i think it is
youtube just deleted all of the super
chats you got to be kidding me really
why did they do that
i want to swear i don't think they i
don't think it can handle this level of
super chat seriously
wow man oh my gosh i apologize to
everybody because we pushed it longer
than we normally do because i think it's
worth the conversation to have i still
i still see super chats in my replay of
it i could only see some oh cool i can
only see like 10 of these
yeah well we'll get to those so here's
the issue
um what what is that law about taxes
going too high in people and then losing
tax revenue yeah so this is this is
known as the laffer curve and basically
there are some left-wing people who will
say the laffer curve doesn't exist but
it's an uneducated take because every
left-wing economist agrees that exists
the only disagreement between the left
and the right is where that parabola
peaks and how high of a tax rate you can
get away with how that change is based
on industry but regardless of what tax
rates have been generally speaking
federal revenues have never exceeded 20
percent of gdp so there's no real reason
to believe we could ever have anything
greater than that in federal revenue for
a sustained period of time regardless of
what the tax rate is
i'm gonna try and see if i can find an
alternative way to pull up the super
chats sorry so um or usually we read the
super chats on the show well normally we
do yeah and we do at 9 30 but i was like
this is a good conversation and well
let's we should really talk about it's
kind of incredible we haven't talked
about it yet i don't think it should be
cut into the second part of the show um
i think really think we should talk
about what was the big story of the
weekend was this this mass unit let me
let me answer the tax thing real quick
uh so we don't get away from it
so uh
what happens with with taxes is when you
raise the tax rate you reduce trade
volume reducing trade volume actually
reduces the amount of money you make i
actually agree with taxing the rich i
think we need to increase the tax
brackets i think they've not been
increased in a long time and it's not so
much a percentage base it's that if
you're making 250 like right now i think
the top brackets were like 250 plus so
like somebody who makes 13 million a
year and a salary is paying the same
percentage someone makes 250 that's
crazy
i certainly think we can raise the
brackets so we space things out and we
end up taxing the rich more
the uh the majority of millionaires i
think run what are called um what did
the new york times call it
uh i don't know what time it's called
they they they rich people that like the
majority of the one percent are like
auto dealers and like plumbing companies
and construction companies the people
they're people who own small uh small
businesses with a few franchises who
make more than a million dollars a year
and that's that's the top point one
percent then there's a small handful of
billionaires like in a couple hundred
but billionaires is based on uh
net worth which is very often like
imaginary numbers
so
if you raise capital gains
you reduce trade volume in the market
reducing trade volume reduces your
revenues the laffer kirby's referring
yeah so just raising rates at 90 doesn't
change anything it just disrupts the
system and causes major hiccups although
i i said i agree with with taxing the
rich i think the issue is for me
when i when i when i made this point
about abortion and then all of these
people associated with the left were
like that's just they would just do a
c-section they would just do induced
labor they don't know what the legal
definition is they don't know the cdc
definition and they don't know what the
democrats tried to do instead of
actually engaging honestly and
legitimately saying that's an
interesting point the law is making
there they just
ignore it say i'm stupid or just don't
even engage with the issue i don't know
who you're specifically talking about
but um
i think we well i'm sitting here and i
think we engage with it quite well yeah
yeah so we should we should um continue
talking about i mean i think we should
let's talk about the the the shooter man
yeah so he was uh a self-described
authoritarian leftist
who believed in the great replacement
place him on the political map wherever
you think that makes sense he claimed he
was a populist as well
he also claimed a number of other things
like what i can tell you right now i'm
pulling it up um hold on let me grab my
uh while you're pulling up can you tell
me the name of the mass shooter from
chicago the matt what mass shooter from
chicago the one who killed uh was it got
killed uh from the same weekend wait
chicago or are you talking about the one
in milwaukee chicago there's 17 people
who got shot no there wasn't 17 people
in chicago yeah
there were no that was that was
milwaukee you're wrong can you look it
up yeah i can't actually hold it up
before the show sure
appears a police report from may 14th
saturday 17 people were shot
why didn't you know the name of this
shooter wait
i can't see it i can't see it press
release milwaukee friday may 3rd oh
milwaukee that's what i said that's what
i said you got me i was wrong
i was wrong i thought it was chicago
you're right no it's milwaukee and i
you're absolutely right i hate that one
right sorry i saw that video you posted
earlier today you said it wasn't covered
you know mainstream media didn't cover
it right the chicago one i was thinking
of was was i think three people got shot
sorry i think that's my bad yeah i i own
that one yeah chicago was four people
who got shot and i confused them okay no
that's okay but you said like um you
said that the mainstream media didn't
cover those stories right
no no that's not what i said would you
say i said what's the name of the
shooter from milwaukee
i want your video earlier today
why isn't it a national conversation no
that's not what you said yeah well i
mean keep up the video
not really you can't pull up your own
video
so if i'm
if you want me to go through youtube and
spend a minute to find the source and
find the exact minute 20 minute segment
where i started
you could pull up the trend you pull up
the subtitles and go right to it
i don't know how to do that you know how
to do that i can tell you right now
okay we we spent time looking up data
and tell me what i said you said that
the mainstream media didn't cover it
okay i'll i'll apologize and i'll
clarify what i meant okay it's not a
national conversation okay we said that
about everything you said that same
exact thing about every one of the
shootings you went through and every
single one i did a simple google search
of and not only did i find local media
reports i found it on cnn nbc news not
the affiliate okay good right because i
pulled up those stories in my video
so just just to clarify if i was
imprecise i apologize
what i mean to convey is why why are we
having a nationalist i want to be clear
though about why that matters because
here we're doing independent media right
and the point is that we criticize
mainstream media the time i mean i do
the same thing i pull up mainstream
media stories and i criticize how things
are covered all the time for example um
i'm sure on this show you've covered uh
the the the string of uh you know thefts
smash and grabs that are happening in
for example i don't know san francisco
or something like that like rite aids
you probably say that's the reason why
rite aids are closing um
but you know we never cover at the same
fact walgreens said they were closing
because of that right some places i'm
sure some places we covered that one
time when it announced that they were
doing it right right but maybe maybe
reference it a couple sure maybe and
also mainstream media this is not a tim
pool issue this is an entire media issue
the mainstream media has covered these
stories ad nauseam over and over again
and if you look up the stats when it
comes to uh
well i'm sorry man i don't mean to
interrupt you but if we want to get at
the core of my argument it's not the
media is not talking about it because i
used mainstream news sources in my
coverage no no what i'm bringing up is
why it's important that i
expect better from you in terms of doing
i know you made a mistake you're even
admitting you made a mistake for the
milwaukee thing right right i know and i
was funny because i was so sure of
myself and i was so wrong right right it
happens it happens it happens it happens
to everybody um you know but um
i'm bringing up what you said earlier in
your video today where you for each
story said that the mainstream media
just didn't cover these things right so
i'm going to clarify that yes
i'll i know you're clarifying that i'm
just bringing up why i think that's
important right
as an independent media outlet your
viewers are coming to you for news that
they think is of higher quality than
what they find in the mainstream correct
that's that's the goal right it's the
same for me it's the same for every
other show that i
watch and help you if you read the law
the democrats are trying to pass if
you're going to do that what are you
talking about well how is it that i read
the law that democrats tried to pass and
you didn't what are you talking about
right now can we let's let's focus on
what we're talking about right now right
you're saying we're striving for a
higher standard in news right you're
mischaracterizing my intention to make
an argument i didn't make no no no i'm
telling you i'm why i think it's
important that i pointed out that's at
all that's all right why are you taking
it like an attack i'm not attacking at
all i'm talking to your viewers about
why that's important that i did that i
think independent media should be held
up to a higher standard of you and i
even on my own show i agree are going to
criticize mainstream media's failures i
think a lot of times we just don't do
that um i think a lot of times media and
i've criticized the left on this too um
we often say oh no we're just
independent media it happens i made a
mistake whatever no if this was cnn who
made that mistake you made or a mistake
that i made on my show you were i would
not just go oh anderson cooper
apologized it's no big deal no we would
expect them to do better and we'd hold
them accountable to that mistake what
would you expect them to do what do you
mean like i've seen i got a story wrong
uh well what would you expect them to do
you you're apologize apologize right
they incorrect they correct it right
correct like like the daily basis let's
use them as an example correct but see
here's the thing we're now uh two hours
into this live show and we're supposed
to do a members-only show yeah and
that's the super chat i mean i don't
know
i'm here all night um you know if i
think you should probably make a video
and let people know about that because
they're not going to catch it two hours
ago
that the mainstream media did in fact
actually cover those shootings
so i think you should make a video
pointing out that you haphazardly
labeled a public figure q on supporter
even though he wasn't and then we're
searching for evidence
are you going to make a video saying
this guy whose name i'd be smurched on
air by characterizing him as having
views he didn't have
are you going to are you going to look
into all of james o'keefe's uh work and
make sure that you didn't mis
incorrectly label him something well i
specifically mentioned that case that he
settled and admitted what he did wrong
even apologize for the harm he caused
the woman that's all i did yeah yeah i
think you mentioned another one the the
minnesota one
the minute you said it oh all i said was
that wasn't true
so the wait do you have a relationship
you have a like you should pull up a
source and confirm that i did i told you
that what he was doing was completely
legal you didn't pull up a source though
okay so here's
here's my point right i i agree we all
make mistakes and and nobody's perfect
i'm just i wonder why it is that nobody
read the law that the democrats just
tried to pass
like how come the damn like how come
these how come you and hassan didn't
read it did hassan read it i'm assuming
he didn't maybe he did
what law are you talking about uh was it
h3 uh http 375. 755. 3755. the the one
we talked about before that didn't pass
why didn't you read it when they were
when they were proposing it 3755. well i
haven't covered it i don't do a daily
show like you do i don't cover every
minutia in the news this bill was
introduced in 20 when was it introduced
february i just didn't cover it wasn't
on my show it wasn't a topic of my show
so
the issue of roe v wade and the
codification of abortion isn't a subject
that you you cover
i don't cover every single issue on my
show no in fact my show actually my
personal show maybe sam covered on the
majority report if we're talking about
mike do you think that in order to have
i'm sorry it was september of 2021 when
i i don't run i don't run a daily show
that talks about politics in general
well it's totally cool if not for me
what i do on my show on my show i
specifically cover what's going on in
the world of right-wing media conspiracy
theories uh from a leftist perspective
yeah and reactionary groups but here's
here's my point um so this is this is
not a topic i would usually cover on my
show then why is it fine on it meanwhile
because you invited me on the show to
talk about it i know but like wouldn't
your answers be like you know i didn't
read the bill
i told you if i had you read it to me
multiple times and once you explained it
to me then i told you my personal
opinion i'm going to tell you my opinion
before you right
noted and accepted
so uh
where what what point were we off on
then let's get back let's get back
because i i did do a 10 i did you know i
pulled the tim pool and went on a
tangent um can we talk about let's go
back to the the shooting i'll address
the news thing go ahead my point is
whenever there's a uh
an extremist right the rolling stone
says the buffalo shooter isn't a lone
wolf he's a mainstream republican which
is just not true
he may have some uh he may share ideas
but the joke is always like you know who
did a dog hitler had a dog you know
things like that
this guy believed in
the great replacement
which uh tucker carlson has also uh
talked about referenced
i wouldn't call great replacement
um
mainstream republican
as as a as a point to say that anyone
who holds that view is a mainstream
republican and that's so the issue with
the rolling stone is that they said he
is and it's because of like a single
thing but the issue is there's also uh
many left-wing personalities uh
identitarians who have expressed similar
ideas this guy also claimed in his
manifesto that he was authoritarian left
i don't think we can take his word for
it i think the dude's a psychopath i
think he's also extremely racist and
extremely dangerous
the issue i see with these things is
why did this story become the national
conversation
it's political
the other mass shootings don't i would
say no i would say it became not
political i would say it became a
national news story because the shooter
streamed his shooting on twitch and
released a long manifesto explaining a
number of reasons why he claims he did
what he did i think if any of the
vegetarianism i think if any no that's
just basic facts in terms of we know
more about right right we know i'm
saying yeah was a huge component he's a
racist
that's part of it but i would also just
state just even outside of that just
literally we know the clear motives of
this shooter which maybe we do i don't
think i don't know the motives of the
shootings in chicago we don't talk about
i mean no the ones you specifically
brought up i mean we know the motives of
those shootings yeah yeah we do that's
specific shooting uh i said the
shootings in chicago but we're going to
talk about we have attendance
we're not talking about the aggregate of
shootings we're talking about specific
shootings there's mass shootings every
weekend in chicago sure okay but but
i'm i'm so this one's obviously my
personal bias being from the city
and
i i feel that the
corporate press and the modern uh
mainstream left is racist
obviously everybody accuses each other
of being racist but i think the core
racism here is the issues surrounding
the black community and gun violence in
chicago that is just completely ignored
every step of the way
and you can have you know a mass
shooting curfew was enacted because
miners were you know involved in a
shootout
it's of course covered in local media
you know there is this one i think there
is a curfew being enacted yeah they did
yeah uh for for minors i'm wondering why
the national story is is always uh i'm
not really wondering i get it it's
political and again the twitch thing for
sure like that makes it huge my my issue
is
i don't like
for this story how the guy like you got
people on the right picking up his left
wing things and people on the left to
give his right wing things and they're
both just pointing at each other like if
this if this this guy i willing to bet
his goal was to foment civil war
and that's why you get these weird
manifestos it's why they do it he
streamed on twitch which is a more
left-wing platform like the goal was to
put it in the face of people and then
make points that either side could grab
just like with christchurch these are
these are these are psychopaths i think
want to just watch the world burn
my my issue is i wish we would have more
conversations at a national level that
were about
the other shootings
you know what i mean i think i think
there are issues that's the point i was
making in my video
so if it came off like i was saying the
media is not covering it what i mean to
say when i say the media is
big
mainstream outlets have not set a news
cycle around the story like they did
with this one
i mean right now sure yeah so i think
that's a failing of the media and uh
it's why you know people were tweeting
me like why aren't you talking about
buffalo people i mean but also but also
i'm not talking about milwaukee also the
media basically reacts to the
media reacts with coverage based on what
an audience is interested in
like if there was massive interest in
one of those stories that they covered
again they all covered those stories
that you brought up and said that there
was no coverage of but it's like local
outlets and and like corporate things
we're talking about cnn and nbc news um
cbs news abc news i saw them all those
are the prime time guys they're not
doing news cycle segments prime time you
talk
you said cnn so i'm referencing no i'm
talking about cnn like cnn.com yeah yeah
news websites to the story right so why
is it that we don't have a national
conversation around these other
instances i mean i'm pretty sure they've
probably done if you look at their
history i'm pretty sure i've seen at
least one uh special on the issue i
think the issue is actually
conservatives are all reactive
you know so they wait for something to
come out and they start quote tweeting
people and it's just like kyle
rittenhouse was trending and it's just
like
because people on the left started
saying and then the right side are
responding to it and that's how you get
certain stories being elevated sure okay
but um let's let's talk about oh we you
you mentioned how what he uh classified
his identity as right
yeah he said he was an off-left populist
or something former communist uh right
former right um he's still in the left
quadrant still in the left i'm not gonna
take his word for it i do oh that's the
thing right you can't take his word for
it right but but in your video you you i
mean you constantly hedge back and forth
on he definitively said that but and the
media lied about is my point like when
they say he's a republican the dude says
he's not you can't just say he's the
other guy well well what what what
left-wing politicians are advocating for
anything that he's mentioned
in terms of uh immigration or anything
like that
do you mean like general identitarianism
no i'm talking about specifically what
this guy said
the reason why he did what he did so do
you know do you know why
uh so first i think the obvious answer
is none right uh well i mean technically
the answer is all of them uh
it it like his motivation it's two
different two different answers right so
so i i'll i will clarify sure when you
have like all the presidential
candidates on the democrat stage raising
their hand saying moratorium on border
crossings and you know free health care
for non-citizens that is policies put
forth that motivate him to do the things
he's doing so he so he claims not that i
believe him right this guy's clearly a
lunatic
but yeah so the policies that are being
acted by democrats are the ones he takes
issue with
sure yeah okay so but we we should not
kowtow to a madman's beliefs and
rantings
based on what he wants to see and
put that burden on other people right no
i don't think we would yeah we locked
the guy up good yeah throw away the key
um he said in his manifesto also that he
you can call me an ethno nationalist
uh he said that if you called him a
neo-nazi that would be fine and uh
another area he said he mocked leftist
and said you're a bigot racist xenophobe
nazi fascist as if we're calling him
that yeah and he said okay and
um and you know he also he's an
identitarian he also um when it comes to
leftism leftism results in a degenerate
hateful society to non-whites he's an
identitarian
oh wait i'm sorry leftism results in a
degenerate hateful society period and
then he continues um and then he went on
for something else where it said to
non-whites on white lands leave while
you still can those were two separate
sentences yeah first of all he's a he's
a dangerous psychopath who should be
locked up um
you know how we deal with these
preventing them in the future is is a
serious challenge our country i want to
try to have but uh here's here's my go
ahead we're we're a fairly
anti-identitarian show i mean like we're
overtly anti-identitarian that's like
the core like one of the core elements
uh and so this is why i oppose the rise
in identitarianism from the democrats
and in schools and all that stuff
because when you tell racial groups to
form
groups based on race you get white
identitarianism along with black
adanitarianism and then you get these
psychopaths
okay like this is this has been the
concern that you know people like me and
like um carl benjamin other
anti-identity benjamin he's like
staunchly anti-vegetarian so if you want
to talk about those who are speaking out
against it there was a meme back and i
think it was like 2016 or even sooner
where i was talking about how uh what we
would not we refer to back then as like
intersectionality was advocating for
racial groups to join together the only
natural conclusion would be white racial
groups agreeing and we don't want that
we don't want
uh
majoritarian-based racial violence we
don't want racial violence at all so we
need to encourage is you know
integration and diversity but when you
have like non-poc poc events when you
have like seattle library doing
dei like non-p poc and poc different
rooms for libraries
you are telling all the white people to
go into a room
you actually had in the sacramento
unified school district they encouraged
kids
racial identity identity groups are you
arguing that uh like a library having a
people of color space is like
something that
we shouldn't do because of something
like this let me ask you to answer your
question sure uh if you tell
non-white people to go in one room
who goes into the other room
wait say the scene 100 people walk to a
library of all different races
one room says poc
one room says non-poc
all of the people who are not uh who are
people of color go into that room
what is the race of the people that all
gather together
in the other room
sure you're gonna say that it's white
correct i'm not gonna say that's what it
is isn't it sure so when you have a room
that says white you know that says non
non-poc and poc you're telling all the
white people to go into a room together
what do you think's going to happen when
you get a bunch of white people together
start telling them that they're
oppressors do you think this is
happening in a way who's calling anyone
a pressure someone's having a library
that's not happening in everyday life
that's not happening in we're not
talking we're not walking through the
world doing this what are you like i'm
confused as to what your anecdote here
is supposed to be so
broader sense let me give you let me see
if i can find the exact source so it's
happening all over the place it's
happened in dearborn it's happened in
seattle it's happened in florida it's
happened it happened in um
i think colin wright's got it if i pull
up on twitter it happened in sacramento
to an extreme degree
uh so here we go uh let me just pull it
up
racial affinity groups
this was uh uh from the anti-racist
classroom sacramento city unified school
district that argued that white students
should form white racial affinity groups
would you agree with that
white students should form white white
racial affinity groups yeah no
why so this is anti-racism though
i mean
i don't agree with that so that so so i
think we i think then we agree my my
concern is that well what
what is a white racial affinity group
they tell all the white kids to go
together and let me read it for you make
sure we get the full context
racial affinity groups offer a structure
of inquiry and can address many needs
they support us in exploring what has
been forbidden forgotten and unhealed
for example in racial affinity groups
white people can discover together their
group identity they can cultivate racial
solidarity and compassion and support
each other in sitting with the with the
discomfort confusion and numbness that
often accompany white racial awakening
they can also discern white privilege
and its impact without the aid of or
dependence on people of color oh that's
a bit different than what i remember
white people who have formed racial
affinity groups report that they
recognize their collective commonality
and shared history as well as the impact
that their privilege has had in other
races and on each racial affinity group
member sure and then it seems like if
that's the case then they would then go
out into society
and um treat people of color in a way
that they weren't treated before treat
them better do you think that's what
white people talk about when they talk
about their shared history how to treat
people better or do you think they talk
if they're if they're getting together
in an anti-racist group then yeah i do
so if you took a bunch of white people
and put it because i could tell you that
the shooter is not going to an
anti-racist affinity group so this is
this is anti-racist classroom a program
from schools yes they're not going to
the students and saying
we're having they're saying we're having
white women when you explain when you're
not just having you know it's letting
them sit down and start talking about
white power you're sitting them sitting
them down and you're guiding a
discussion into what white privilege is
and what do you think happens when a
group of young white kids uh sit down
and talk about white history what do you
think they do what do you what do you
think they say to each other what do you
mean they talk about what sort of you do
you think they say things like men we're
awful or do you think they say things
like lea fair excellence who's who's
they probably don't say either of those
things
who those are just general references
but i mean those are the two ones you
gave me um no one right right my point
is do you think they're speaking
positively or negatively about their
history
neither they're just discussing it why
does that be positive or negative are
they talking about slavery are they
talking about colonization
talking about slavery or colonization
what are they talking about do you think
well if they if this is in the classroom
it's being guided by a teacher correct a
white racial affinity group i i don't
know if it actually says the teacher
would be discussing i think it's it's
telling the kids to form uh if it gives
them and if it gives you it says they
can cultivate i would assume it's it's
unlead
well i don't you can't assume that we
have to know well
i also don't think that if you get a
whole bunch of white kids together they
start talking about leaf eriksen or they
start talking about they probably just
start talking i'm not saying they're
literally talking about leaf eric's okay
but they don't be obtuse okay without
any without any sort of um guidance
they're probably not talking about
anything political at all they're
probably talking about what's going on
in school they're probably talking about
what happened at the
the cafeteria whatever do you think
they're wondering why it is they've been
separated from the other kids of
different races probably not because
they would explain to them what the
purpose of the uh
the anti-racist classroom group is do
you think any of these kids have friends
who are not white probably yeah you what
do you think they ask about why they
can't sit with their friends in the
affinity group it's like a what a 45
minute class or a 30 minute class
whatever it's not like they're not being
segregated for life they're it's a it's
a project it's a class so would you
agree with racial segregation in schools
in some capacity no that's not what this
is but if only white kids are in this
group and other kids aren't allowed in
it would that be racial segregation this
is a specific class to talk about white
privilege right so in some circumstances
would you allow for only white people to
be in the classroom that's not what this
is okay okay hold on
this is a white racial affinity group as
it says right
it says that it's an anti-racist
classroom i can't read that i can't it's
too far for me unfortunately i don't
have the computer it's uh
so white people can discover their group
identity
in the context it specifically mentions
people of color it specifically mentions
multiple times white privilege sure sure
sure i'm not disagreeing but i mean you
know what white privilege is right right
but so you agree with racial segregation
no that's not what this is okay well
hold on it says without the dependence
on people of color tim i know what
you're trying to do no no no no i'm not
trying to do anything i don't i know but
you're trying to do something what am i
trying the fact remains that a school
created a program where only white kids
would be allowed and you're okay with it
now if you don't have the balls to say
you're okay with it fine don't say it
are you okay are you okay are you okay
when a teacher tells uh the boys to line
up on one side of the classroom and
girls line up on the other side of the
class yes why wouldn't i of course so
why wouldn't you be okay with this
racism it's not racism
yeah but the other thing is in sexism
well yeah because we tell boys and girls
do you we tell boys and girls to use
different bathrooms that's fine it would
not be fine to tell black kids and white
kids to use different bathrooms it's not
a fair comparison but that's not what
we're doing here we're not asking black
kids or white kids do you suffer better
no but your point you're you're trying
to make it sound as if gender is it the
difference between the sex is this
comparable to the differences between
racial groups telling a bunch of white
kids to get together without other kids
of other races is racist and i'm not for
it i'm not for it but they're
specifically discussing i don't care
what they're discussing racism i don't
think should be allowed in schools to
say whites only i think that's wrong i
don't care no one's saying that though
you just jump to something complete
literally you could be out the aid of
people of color what do you think that
means okay like you could be you could
be in seattle they said non-poc only
what do you think that means in
california they had a proposition to
remove their civil rights provision from
their own constitution allowing racial
segregation i'm
literally we're literally you you're
bringing up other things that are
completely different now we're talking
about this one specific class that i
don't find a problem with to be quite
honest if this is a world white kids are
alive
in the context of this yes only why
can't i think it's fine an anti-racist
discussion would write
we're not arguing you're agreeing and
i'm assuming that in another classroom
people of course are sharing their
shared experiences too as people of
color what is secretary and then and and
but we're not we don't have to go back
into segregation we're just talking
about this one specific classroom i'm
against segregation in terms of a school
for whites and a school for blacks but
in terms of this one specific class
i think it's fine i think it's fine if
you don't like it that's fine too i
think this is a really
uh unproductive discussion we have both
of our opinions so this is on the record
we're both probably i'm assuming you are
we're both against segregation in terms
of a school for blacks and a school for
whites
i am under the impression that this is
from what you're telling me an
anti-racist class a one-time class
discussion on white privilege and i
think it's fine it's that simple i don't
think we need to opine on this more if
you do
i don't know what else to say about it
to be quite frank i'm giving you exactly
how i feel that's what you want right
i'm telling you how i feel
let me uh let me see if i can pull up
the uh seattle one
it's hard to get the precise language uh
well yeah the virtual cafes
at uh dearborn michigan was a big story
reaffiring our commitment did you hear
this story when they said that they were
having digital digital uh chat rooms and
they were for white and non-white only
i'm not familiar with this story they
call it non-poc and poc only see i think
that's wrong and uh what's your what's
your what's your racial background my
racial background i'm white i know you
are mixed race yeah so for me i think my
my perspective comes from multi-racial
yep i come from a family that dealt with
segregation and they told me exactly
what you're agreeing with is exactly
what they were scared of and so on i'm
like desperately being like this is
crazy you're like it's fine it's fine
it's fine and then i'm like looking back
at the stories from my grandpa and my
parents and they're like this is the
scariest thing we've seen in a long time
and then you just don't care i'm saying
i don't care well no no i'm saying i i
just i just said i just said to
specifically i just said specifically
the talk about white privilege and
anti-racism i think in that context it's
fine that specific context yeah i just i
think we disagree on that so same
argument they made in the same argument
they make today
wait so schools were segregated back in
like the 50s because
uh they were separate separate but equal
they were separating the whites to talk
about white privilege and anti-racism
action there they were they were
justifying the separation on some kind
of physical or academic terms or like
cultural terms like there was a
justification for why it was okay this
time but it was never okay it was never
okay to say one place for one race one
it was never okay right still not what
this is it's just a simple class to
discuss this issue i don't see the
problem with it quite honestly think
because is it is it because you have
white privilege oh yes of course i do so
you're wrong and you're as you as a
white man have white privilege and don't
understand why it's bad to tell i don't
think that's why privileges i actually
have a problem with the word privilege
because i think for people
seems like you're one of them for a lot
of people
they view that word privilege as
something that's being looked at them
negatively and it's just not it's just
not i view white privilege as there are
things in my life that like here's even
better way of putting it if you are a
white person
and everything has gone wrong for you in
terms of you you're homeless
and you can't get a job and you'll be
the most unluckiest person in the face
of the planet
it likely did not happen to you because
you were white that's all it is that's
all it is whereas if you see a black
homeless person who can't get a job
can't you know
things have happened in their life to
get they've lost their home
is a good chance that their race being
black
had part to doing that had part to do in
their situation that's all that is it's
not a positive or negative if you
understand that if you understand that
there are certain things that have not
happened to you because you're white
then you understand what black people or
uh you know uh latino people or asian
americans
go through that you just haven't had to
go through it's not a negative or
positive just understanding how other
people go through life that's all it is
it's not a negative thing to understand
you have white privilege
we're going to jump to the super chats
that weren't deleted i apologize to
everybody when you you i don't know why
um
we've had way more superstitions in the
past but it just awesome when they were
gone
but uh
my attitude i'll give you one last
thought on like but we also we also
didn't we also didn't talk about the
shooting though we just didn't talk
about let's let's let's let's do that
for a member segment i know we're making
everybody stay a little bit late but uh
we'll we'll get that one up i feel like
that's important stuff i mean i know you
i know but it's but we're like we're
half an hour over already all right all
right all right and the super chat the
last thing i want to say is um
i feel like when you have a school that
is predominantly run by wealthy uh
elites you know
sacramento san francisco tends to be
california i think is like
overwhelmingly white
then they create a classroom where they
say come on all the white kids are going
to come in and we're going to talk about
privilege
and they talk about how much privileged
they are and and the things they have
over other races
i think the likely outcome is going to
be a bunch of white kids
hearing that they have better things
that they've done better that through
their history they've achieved or taken
more than other races
what would they say i mean that sounds
like what they're going to tell the kids
i mean i i i think someone should talk
to these kids who partook in this class
and see what they learn i mean that's i
mean we're just
i mean i'm not saying what they learn in
there i'm just going by what the class
says
about what they possibly took out of it
i haven't done anything i just think
that if you take a bunch of white people
and them to go to a room by themselves
to talk about privilege they're not
going to have a negative conversation
about themselves
like
if i ask i'm going to seriously let me
ask you i'm going to seriously i mean
again i can't this is me pontification
i'm going to assume that if you tell
kids to do that sort of thing in a class
that there is a teacher or some sort of
i don't know anti-racist advocate
someone leading the class and helping
these children along and taking part in
this activity that's what i'm going to
assume we should find we should find out
we should contact the school and find
out how this went ask if we could talk
to if uh we could uh send some questions
that the children the kids these are how
old were these kids
it's a great school so kindergarten
through
maybe have them answer what they learned
like the paper interesting
what if i what if i did like an event
and it was called like um
leftist affinity
and it was to have a conversation around
all of the horrible things that leftists
said done throughout the past several
hundred years and to understand their
privilege
do you think if i brought in a bunch of
you didn't listen to anything what i
said just said about white privilege
though it's not that it's not that's not
what it is at all okay so if i if you do
you think that if i took a bunch of
people of any group and put them in a
room they would talk critically about
themselves or
talk positively about themselves i mean
for four of us are in here right now
right and we're just having a regular
conversation and
and clearly i
will not accept you know uh like i'm
like this is what i know to be true this
is what's right you say the same thing
sheamus says the same thing so my
attitude is and and i don't want to go
in circles so we'll go to super chat but
and i'll give you you know i don't i
don't take the final word but my point
is i think if you try to do your best
and tell a bunch of white people to keep
forming groups or to go and or to have
like rooms that are only for white
people or like like dearborn did like
they did in the library i think was in
seattle like the school's doing like
we've seen in a bunch of other states
like in atlanta they did it the the
principal took the black kids out like
you're you're you're telling people to
segregate whether it's like harsh
segregation or not you're you're making
the problem worse and you'll end up with
deep racists that's why we should we
should we should find out what these
things actually do we should actually do
a legitimate study ask these uh students
who took part in this whether you know
first second third it's high school we
should ask them what they got out of
these sort of courses what they got out
of this anti-racist classroom i think
that'd be very interesting to find out i
think we should encourage people of all
races to get together and have a
conversation with each other but
what if what if what if these kids
answer and they say this was a very
these the white kids and the people of
color they broke mine and said this was
a very positive thing we went through
and it actually made our relationship
with our you know the white kids say our
relationship with our black friends is
better black kids say their relation
with their white friends are better what
if that was what they found and got out
of this what would you you know so what
do you think this is what i was told it
was like pre-1964
that plus ev ferguson like derek bell's
argument that uh derek bell the critical
race theorist argues plus e v ferguson
was correct when it clearly wasn't and
so you actually had people arguing
everybody was better off critical race
theorists have argued that before the
end of segregation the black community
had its own economy and by ending
segregation it forced them under the
white economy which gave the white
people power over them so these are the
kind of conversations they had in the
past as to why that but segregate but
segregation didn't make the relationship
between whites and blacks better i agree
yeah i'm saying what if the kids what
they were saying it was
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no that's that's so read
derek bell like read his thoughts on
plessy v ferguson that's he argued
segregation was a good thing he's a
critical race theorist along with
kimberly crenshaw
let's read uh let's read i'm so i
apologize man no it's yeah i'm not
familiar with that specific uh thing but
i think if you if we should this is a we
should reach out to this school and we
should find out what the kids got out of
it in uh um in in ferguson and in uh um
uh st louis baltimore ferguson obviously
in saint louis and baltimore they were
circulating a letter among black lives
matter which was like the writings of
derek bell and advocating for plus cv
ferguson and all that stuff but we'll
try and read as many super chats as we
have
uh okay
uh if you haven't already smash the like
button that we went long because these
things happen we went way long we'll uh
we'll read as many super texts as we
have but
i apologize youtube deleted them i
i can try and find a way to to get them
back i just i might be able to find
another way to get them back give me a
second they're in the uh the
monetization section right that's
without
in your youtube studio
ah
nice
there
okay can i pull this up somehow
oh yeah
okay i have them sweet
but they're formatted in a very
difficult way that we and there's not
all of them
usually all of them are there oh okay
you're right you're right going back
basically forever right yep okay cool
hey guys good news oh yeah thanks matt
i'll try to read them
uh we'll pull over this tab which we
normally don't pull over and i will try
to read these super chats i don't know
when they came in though because um oh
yeah are they reversed
i think i think they're coming in
reverse chronological order actually
okay
so let me see if i can uh
uh
i don't know where you're coming in from
it might be it might be from the
beginning okay okay it is reverse
chronological order reverse chronologic
chronological order
all right anthony says citing white
privilege is just a way to defer
responsibility if you're poor and white
it's your fault but if you're poor and
non-white it's someone else's fault
at any point you know and we'll just
keep reading more i suppose but unless
you have something to say
all right let's see how do you usually
do this
we read it i'll just i'll just direct it
okay go ahead what was it again
this one wasn't directed at
you necessarily i don't think it's just
a general point said citing white
privilege is just a way to defer
responsibility if you're poor and white
it's your fault but if you're poor and
non-white it's someone else's fault no
no no that's not what it is at all it's
not it is at all it's not your fault
it's just that the odds are that
whatever you went through in your life
the reason you are
in economic trouble the reason it's it's
not because you were white there were
other externalities that caused that
issue that's all that's all it's not
blaming anybody
all right uh
should i read the mean ones
oh please yeah of course
matt why does sam cedar with 1.17
million followers only average about 25k
likes on his youtube videos sure by the
way great conversation i think that's
actually a good number to get in terms
of likes actually i don't think that's a
bad number yeah it's a decent number i
guess but also his show has always been
he his show was from the um his show
started in his show actually started
with gene garofalo back in what was it
2000 wow for
um on air america it was a radio show
like a terrestrial radio show and so his
audience actually mostly listens to the
show via podcast um so those youtube
numbers are mostly from
a very specific subjection of his
audience it's a completely different he
has 25k is a good amount of likes it's
so it's good yeah yeah like that's what
i get i don't know uh all right let's
see i don't know if that's accurate
that's what this person's saying but um
yeah heather coren says he just proved
tim's point some people view this
negatively making race center and
calling all white people bad constantly
which they do is going to create more
racists of all races not less no what i
said was the term privilege i think does
cause problems i think we could find a
better term for that same exact thing i
think people for some reason hear the
word privilege and think oh you're
privileged that's not what white
privilege means so you know i think
maybe to uh help this conversation along
maybe we should find a different uh
terminology for the exact same thing
which is basically just if you're a
white you need to just come to the
realization that there are things that
people of other races people of color
black um latino asian american they go
through experiences that you don't
because you are white it's not saying
you are bad it's just come to that
realization you can be going through
hardships and troubles there could be
things happening to you that are truly
horrible and you know
unfair but it's not happening to you
likely because it's white like for
example if the same thing was happening
to a black person there is a chance that
his race or his or her race did play
some role
in that hardship or difficulty that
they're going through can i ask you
something because you referenced asian
americans why is it that basically by
every economic indicator that's used to
demonstrate white privilege exists
asians outperform white people well it's
not always just economics i mean are you
i'm saying i'm saying all the indicators
that exist are you one indicator that
exists the fact that or would you deny
that there is anti-asian hatred sent us
a sentiment across this no i know i
would not deny that
from who what do you mean from who who
who's got
from people who are using what uh who
are attacking asian people who's
attacking issues anybody do you have
examples of this sure there's been white
people who've done it there's been black
people who've done it oh i didn't ask
you that i'm asking for the stories
about asian people you brought up race
well we're talking about race we're
talking about in the context of race yes
well i i i asked you like where is the
where the asian attacks happening oh in
new york sure in california well that's
where there are uh major populations of
asian people right who's who's like so
uh
is there a reason the asians are being
attacked oh yes because of uh sentiment
via like uh racism due to covid19
beliefs that it came from china and uh
people um or
purposely came from china um or you know
and they're taking it out on completely
innocent asian americans and a lot of
the times uh they're not even attacking
uh chinese people which wouldn't make it
right but they're even wrong on that
sense because they're attacking korean
americans they're attacking japanese
americans um and it's just it's wrong
and that's something that
for example white people do not
experience they usually do not
experience racist attacks like asian
americans do
in the aftermath of the coven 19
pandemic but what about in general do
you think white people experience racist
attacks for being white i'm sure it's
happened but it's not like it's it's the
that's an anomaly it's not as often as
for example a black person or a
latino person is that your feeling or is
that a fact i mean you could look it up
i'm sure it would be true i mean we just
had a story we just had a story about
the um you know the 10 people who got
killed uh because there was a racist
attack in a supermarket against um black
people specifically from the shooter
that's what sure sure yeah but how many
people died last year in extremist
attacks i don't have to look at those
things 29 okay according to the
anti-defamation league
i mean you had nearly a thousand
shootings in chicago in massachusetts
like i think it was like uh
400-ish
people died in mass shootings in chicago
the entire the entirety of last year
and so it's just like i feel like the
conversation about white privilege went
20 years you don't think you don't think
the the the
situation in those neighborhoods that
have um you know uh
led to what you're describing you don't
think there's anything to do with the
historic uh racism in this country you
don't think those neighborhoods are
predominantly you know they've maybe
been redlined um there's been um you
know uh do you know why they're shooting
each other in chicago
it's different for every reason right
it's mostly like honor honor shootings i
mean that's that's that's can you can
you pull up something to to back that up
i've i've never even what do you mean
honor shootings what's that like uh you
diss me i take your life okay i mean i
i'm familiar with that do you have any
anything to i uh
we should go through super chats but i
can pull up for you actually sure i
actually i uh that'd be really
interesting for one uh i'll cite myself
as a source as having covered and lived
in chicago for you know 23 years and i
actually went night crawling with a
couple journalists one who's like really
famous now and uh we we night you're
familiar with that crawling yeah get the
radio and you go chase around and we we
interviewed uh this crime prevention uh
woman a local in the black community who
is arguing in favor of gun rights
but against gun violence and she was
talking about one of the misconceptions
in chicago is that it's gang violence
when it's actually more like um
somebody smack talk to my girl
and if you do that i mean you're gonna
you're gonna pay for it i would love to
see uh more information about that for
sure you should definitely pull up but
you want to get back to the super chats
or while you pull it up yeah uh
we'll get to super chats i wish we had
more time man i hate to well i guess
you're gonna have to invite me back yeah
but
there's a there's an opportunity
there's two videos i mean definitely
absolutely there's two videos on my
channel one is the interview with uh
this woman i forgot her name it was
years ago and then also when we went
night crawling but i mean i can also
just speak as much as it's not as
valuable as a direct source as someone
who lived in chicago and lived on the
south side having
like witnessed people doing it we know
why it happens
so anyway let's reach more let's read
some more super chats we gotta read more
um i i don't know if we're gonna have
time for a members only segment unless
you know you guys are all cool with it
all right let's see i can't uh uh twimmy
says i can't believe in 2022 tim of the
disgraced show shim cass is advocating
against segregation shameful
heavens shim cast wonderful show let me
tell you
all right jeffrey faff says sounds like
george wallace
leftist atlanta teacher segregated the
students if white people have privilege
wouldn't they use it to their advantage
um
sure i mean it happens what do you mean
what are they what are they i'm not so
following so uh in california sure are
you familiar with the proposition in
2020 to repeal the nondiscrimination
language from their constitution i'm not
no
excuse me
oof it was called like the affirmative
action bill or something
and uh there was a provision in the
constitution that says you can't
discriminate on the basis of race sex
national origin
uh for purposes of
public public education or contracting
and one other thing they wanted to
remove that because they said we can't
enact affirmative action without it
my issue with it was
i kind of feel like if you give
the government which includes all the
smaller local governments the ability to
discriminate in the basis of race like
my question to you is i'll start with
this do you think that there are racist
white people
racist white people yeah
yes i think so personally do you think
that they're racist by people in
government personally i do sure
do you think that if racist white people
in government were given the opportunity
to segregate on the basis to
discriminate on the basis of race they
would discriminate against people of
color
probably i think they would so when
california tried doing this i was like
hey that's a big no for me but it was
actually the democrat-led effort at the
national level to do
so you had tons of federal-level
democrats who are advocating for this
repeal to me that i find that shocking
so the point was if white people have
privilege wouldn't they use it to their
advantage it sure looks like it
sure i mean it happens yeah well the
republicans opposed it it failed but the
democrats were pushing it and i'm glad
they lost
i would have to look more into that i'm
not familiar with it
all right
jeffrey faff says did he did he just
admit cnn and msnbc really put ad
revenue before black lives being killed
in chicago they set the narrative but he
trusts the media
well um you don't have to respond i'm
just no that's fine i mean i i mean i'm
sure they do i mean what do you what do
you want they're a corporate media
outlet what is their purpose
all right let's read some more it's
really hard to read the super chats away
in this weird very small yeah very small
and like is there a way to zoom in zoom
in
go to view and enlarge it no the size
isn't isn't mainly the issue it's the
formatting normally we like to make sure
we get people's uh questions from
earlier in the show so we don't miss
them so i'll go back and then we'll
we'll try and go forward
uh but it's like reverse reverse the
order we normally do it in so i'll
switch it
all right make 1984 fiction again says
tim there is no such thing as a viable
baby up until three years old and that's
being generous that argument is
infuriating what does that mean
well he's saying children are wholly
dependent on uh their mother at an early
age
yeah i mean
i i get it i've heard the arguments it's
it's tough i don't have all the answers
that's all i can really say
uh they're dependent on a very different
way though i mean you can't say that
going out and buying your child food is
the same as your your child literally
being inside your body eating the
nutrients that you intake that's not the
same yeah but now they give you the
right to kill your child if you don't
want to do it
do what no one's advocating for killing
yeah unborn children that's what
abortion is you're killing an unborn
child
so you're right
it's arguing there's a difference sure
between having a child inside of you and
providing resources for them but parents
are responsible for taking care of their
children
right yes a child yes yes an unborn
child is a child a person yes and there
are people no one in all of history who
has ever referred to a group of humans
as not being full persons has ever been
right in the final analysis ever does
does does a uh does a fetus
get uh child support from their father i
would absolutely say that men should be
held to account for the children that
they create absolutely i think i think
before the child is born men should pay
bro
yeah i think men should i yes i think
that men should have to pay for their
children 100 percent i'm just but
specifically what i'm saying yes those
are children sheamus thinks they should
be married before yeah yeah exactly and
if a man abandons a woman who is
pregnant with his child he should
absolutely be on the hook for taking
care of her and that child yeah all
right that's but you know
in the uh you know the current laws we
have that's not the case it should be
good are you gonna are you gonna
advocate for that he does yeah i do yeah
i'm happy good he opposes premarital sex
yeah all right that's i mean like
i think it's interesting because like
sheamus
catholic conservative what do you think
about that one though about uh about
should a um of a uh the father of the
the person who impregnates a woman the
male who pronounced pregnancy woman
should he be uh responsible for child
support payments from i don't know i
guess uh the moment of conception right
yes okay uh but but it's a question for
me of law right i think
one of the problems we have is cultural
enforcement i think we should do these
things i think a man should be
responsible the moment the woman is like
yeah i'm praying it's like well tell me
what you need and what to do and he's
going to take care of it
i don't know how much i like the
government's involvement in like a
person's
private matters because we've seen
instances where
even mothers have argued they don't want
child support anymore but the
government's been like we don't care and
then force the guy to put the money
through the government and to her that's
a very specific case that's not the vast
majority of the of the issues they're
but i mean you're in favor of the state
in enforcing
like the private matters between a man
and a woman if uh if uh if uh if a woman
is going to have a baby then yes
absolutely the father should be oh wow
yeah and that's a more conservative
position than i would have expected you
don't what we have a father's rights guy
that's actually usually a right no no no
i think approach i think i assumed you
were more on the side of like
individual
you know like why would why would one
have the right to choose but not not the
man i just assumed you would well the
right to choose is based on the body
what do you mean
when it's it's my body my choice right
it's not my baby or my fetus my choice
we're talking about it's a woman's body
that's being used and she has um the
ability to decide what she wants to do
with her body does the man have a right
to choose in any any capacity with his
own body sure yeah like does the man
have a right over whether or not the
woman has a baby or not
uh in terms of like if they decide
together to have a baby then yeah like
let's say a men and women hook up and
they they both were like oh she's
pregnant it's not his body so but can he
choose to just leave it can he choose to
just leave it yeah um no
so you you think the man should have no
say in the matter in any capacity well
he has plenty of say in the matter he
could just
not have sex with that woman the woman
could not have sex too sure so so she
has so the woman is right she's in the
man doesn't
but with her because it's her body yes
what if the man is like i don't want to
pay for it well he's got to why does he
have because that's the law why doesn't
the woman have to pay for it she does
pay for it with her body and raising the
child but she can get rid of it
for
foreign
no i'm saying
if like i recognize a woman it's a
woman's body but how can you argue
pro-choice for the woman but but not the
man's right to because everyone's
pro-choice is talking about the woman's
body it's not
what do you think pro-choice is we're
talking about women's bodies
that's what the pro-choice movement is
well i i assumed see i i think the guy
should pay i mean literally it's
literally in it's literally in
everything they say my body my choice
that's the thing it's not my fetus my
choice it's my body my choice right
that's the whole thing roe v wade argues
with the 14th amendment right i thought
you were making an equality argument
equality like
if the woman can choose to terminate or
not it's her choice because it's her
body yes right the man could also choose
to sever or not it's his choice
sever what are you talking about sever
ties well no he's responsible for the
life that he'll bring into this world if
that's what she decides to go forward
with so men have less of a say in the
birth of the baby like look here hear me
out do you think it would be okay if a
woman got an abortion because she
couldn't afford a baby like let's say
she's six weeks pregnant she has no
money and and she's like i got i can't
afford this sure because it's her body
yes
but based on finances sure what if the
guy has no money and he's homeless well
then the um the the courts take that
into consideration
so
i'm not asking you about the course i'm
saying do you think the guy should be
like i have no money i can't have a baby
well then he should have considered that
before he went ahead and did an act that
resulted in the birth of a child but why
should the why does the woman not have
that because it's her body it's it's
really simple exactly no she had the
option not to use her body to engage in
the act which creates children she did
have that no
we're specifically talking about the
right to your body and there is i mean
you guys disagree that's that's fine i
mean but this is a this is the position
no i i i mean i i i think uh you know i
think we agree i'm just confused as to
what your what your principal position
is because it doesn't seem to make sense
to me how does that make sense i think
you have two human beings who are of
equal rights within under the eye of the
government but you one says
i am six weeks pregnant but i can choose
to end the life of this to end right now
now hold on but the major thing is that
the choice is her choice over her body
right yeah yeah yeah and so the male's
body is not involved so there's no
choice involved here i'm talking about
finances okay so like that's where the
responsibility of it comes in so a woman
who's two a woman can get an abortion
because she's broke
right sure that's her body right right
okay so a woman can be like i'm not
gonna have a baby i can't afford it yes
was there any responsibility for her
when she decided to engage in sex with
without and then getting pregnant is
there any responsibility i mean sure but
at the end of the day it's her body and
she has the right to decide what she
what happens
so
what about the man
does he he has he has no say in the
matter at all i mean if a man wants if a
man does not want a child he should not
engage in acts that
requires
it's really if he does want a child
though there's many ways he could go
about getting a child if that if his
partner for example doesn't want a child
you know that your argument is an
inversion of the right-wing argument
like like they're identical in in
principle but they make no sense
logically to me i mean i would i would
say that my position is the uh the
position that most people on the left
have right right so
when sheamus says
both the mother and the father have to
be responsible for what they what they
did
and the man has to pay and the woman
should be able to kill the baby that's
logically sound i get it both have
they've done it the baby's there your
position is one gets to say one doesn't
because we're talking i'm talking about
finance is not a body
okay you keep changing at the subject
because because finances just when it
comes to a woman's choice the finances
are just irrelevant because a woman's
choice is to is because the man doesn't
have anything happened to his body
there's nothing there's nothing he
doesn't have anything happened to the
body why should if the woman chooses to
have a baby it's her her decision sure
so the man does why does a man have to
chew like the man has no choice to have
it have the kid i think he does he could
just
not have done what he did to and result
in a pregnancy so like you're cr so
here's the problem the 14th amendment
this is my confusion the 14th amendment
says equality under the law you can't
create a circumstance in which for any
reason body or otherwise one person has
a legal right another person doesn't
have if the woman can decide to for
financial reasons terminate a pregnancy
or keep it under under any argument the
man would have to have under the 14th
amendment the same equality under the
law now if you want to make an argument
about oman's right to an abortion
because it's her body i agree it's her
body but now we're talking about
responsibility that one can end and one
can't that doesn't jive under the 14th
amendment i don't understand that it
makes no sense i mean what you're
arguing from a 14th amendment
perspective which is roe v wade sure but
it's not the same thing but
equality under the law means men and
women have to be able to make this same
financial so you're saying that every
situation where a man
uh did not want to have a child and is
forced to pay child support your claim
is that it's currently uh
unconstitutional
is if i'm so my position is the guy
should pay
your position was your but you're you're
asking me this i said from the beginning
i think the guy should pay okay so we
agree but i think i think we need
cultural changes okay my question is i
don't understand how you reconcile that
i mean if we want to talk about culture
my position is if you want if you want
to talk about if you want to talk about
cultural changes that's fine i
could agree with cultural changes but
that doesn't change the fact that
in the situation where as it happens
right now if a woman does not want a
pregnancy uh six weeks like you said not
viable completely legal to do in this
country
she can have an abortion so when it
comes to finance a man cannot
force her to have the abortion a man
cannot claim he doesn't want to pay for
a child women pay a child support to men
for what for the baby for the baby what
do you mean if if the men and women get
together and they have kids sure and the
woman is you know she works at uh vice
media making 70k a year and the
husband's homeless should she pay child
support to him
she's not carrying the child no after
it's born after child support is after
it's born if they're together then no
why would they no they split up they
split up yeah is he taking care of the
child they have dual custody
is he taking care of the child dual
custody means they both have equal
access to this i mean i'm sure she's
making sure if that's the case that the
child is the government should mandate
women pay child support to men i mean if
it's if it's that situation where the uh
the man is in squalor taking care of the
child then yes sure oh what what if what
if the man makes 50k and the woman makes
80.
i mean if the court decides i'm fine
with that so uh simple question
simplified women should pay the same
child support men should pay in the same
circumstances sure if they're if they're
if they're both taking care of the child
sure yeah okay there we go that's one
way to get it
all right let's see we got well uh
that's what you were asking this whole
time because that's not how it read to
me so we could have got
we gotta get past that a lot earlier
well because my question is if you're
making a 14th amendment argument for uh
abortion how do you ignore the the like
that men don't have a say it doesn't
make sense
well just read some more channels
yeah yeah so what what uh if a man
pressures a woman to have an abortion
what should the penalty for that be
a man pressure yeah yeah so you're
saying a man can't make woman have an
abortion i mean what if he does what
should the penalty be well what do you
mean by make like he he puts pressure on
her he coerces her into doing it he
threatens her he says he'll hurt herself
are there are there well that that's the
complaint so here's the thing
do you think it should be a different
penalty than if a man threatens a woman
for some other reason like if a man says
you know i'll hit you if you don't
listen verse i'll hit you if you don't
get an abortion do you think that those
are different circumstances that should
incur a different penalty if if he does
something to actually convincing her
would he threaten her she has an
abortion because if a woman says i got
this abortion because amen threatened me
should there be a legal penalty for that
i would actually love to see if there
are laws in the books for that because
that'd be interesting for sure i think
um you know there are in terms of like
if a man was to punch a pregnant woman
his pregnant partner and that would
result in abortion uh that would be
considered in this country a fetal
homicide we have a specific
classification for that in those
scenarios yes so there are certain
circumstances in certain states where
you can be charged with homicide for
killing an unborn child
but homicide means you've killed a human
it's that's what homicide means it's
specifically called a fetal homicide yes
but you're acknowledging that it is
homicide sure though he killed a person
but what you're saying is under specific
circumstances if the mother doesn't want
that child killing it becomes acceptable
because we're now talking about the
issue of it her being her body and she
has the authority over herself over here
she's not making a decision about
herself she's making decisions about the
child that's well they're all the the
disagrees with that though the law
agrees that i was wrong okay well then
right i think you guys like
sure but then then i guess my final
question is since it's an issue of her
body would you argue that since this is
just about her body it's not about a
right to kill a child that if the child
is viable it should be
delivered and then saved with medical
technology
do you think that should be the
requirement if the child's viability if
the child has passed the point of
viability doesn't want to be pregnant
should she be allowed to kill that child
that can survive outside the womb
or should there be a requirement i'm not
talking about the laws in the country
i'm asking about your position sure i
mean if this is just about a woman's
body and there's an opportunity for the
unborn child to live outside of her body
because it is viable is she able to
abort the child and kill it or would you
argue since this is just about her body
and not killing a child that everything
would have to be done to deliver and
save that child it's her body that's my
position
we're not talking about everybody yeah
i'm saying
so so so yeah because when they perform
an abortion procedure they actually
specifically go in and kill the child
they don't simply remove it but you're
talking about something that doesn't
happen it's not happening in this
country are you talking about people
getting abortions
after viability women can't just up and
choose there has to be a reason and and
i told you i read i read citations from
partial guys birth abortionists who have
said the number one reason cited is
depression i think in their practice so
that i think this quantifies the
political issue we have in this country
very simply
my political positions have long been
from from what's called traditional
liberal
for you know what in the first several
weeks pre-viability beyond that i
understand sheamus perspective i have a
a libertarian argument that he's mocked
and doesn't agree with
i don't think you understand it all
what's being said
and i'm not saying that to be
disrespectful i'm saying
when when i pulled the law and we're
trying to explain to you what the
definition of abortion is according to
the us government and you don't
understand it you say it's her body but
we didn't mention her body we're talking
about a baby being delivered but you
defer to some
something that's not being talked about
i don't know if we can i mean i i
we discussed this i don't view it as i
view it as an issue of it's
if the if the fetus is in the mother's
body
and going by the current laws we have
right now
which i uh for uh ravi waiting sorry
this is the issue
we're trying to ask you about your
advocacy my advocacy is what my advocacy
is what exactly is legal in this country
right now so you think
but then you but then
let me try this let me try this there's
two there's two babies
there's a pregnant woman
and she's eight and a half months along
there's another baby next to her
that
is freshly delivered at eight and a half
weeks the babies are completely i got a
better idea twins here we go a woman is
pregnant with twins one is born
can they kill the one still in her
or no
if there's something that needs if
that's what absolutely needs to be done
yes that's the law so you say no no no
no you can't you can't say my position
is the law that falls out well that's
just the law he's asking you
philosophically is it immortal
i don't care about this terminate the
baby but i don't care about the
philosophical discussions because what
matters is the law these philosophical
discussions help inform what the law
should be they don't so no but the law
is what it is right now it's her body is
a philosophical alliance that you're
making no that's the democrats just
tried to change the law last week okay
but they didn't because they failed
thanks to people like me
because people like me
who oppose
uh terminating the life of a baby when
it's when it can survive outside the
womb
we oppose that okay we've always opposed
right bill clinton all of us since going
back the traditional liberals the
traditional liberal position so sheamus
is the classical conservative position
i'm the traditional liberal position and
you're the progressive leftist position
so you can understand why everyone on
the right calls me a leftist because i
actually say first term you know
pro-choice or whatever and that is so
far from where republicans are and
conservatives are but then you guys are
sitting here saying a woman can decide
to terminate a viable baby if she
chooses that is so far removed from me
no no i never
when we're talking about a viable
pregnancy the laws in this country are
that there needs to be
a reason that it's done where the baby
is going like
why why is it so hard for you to
understand that i agree with what the
laws currently are because i'm asking
you about your moral position and
advocacy
not what the law is my moral
advocacy in every state is that it is a
woman's choice because it is her body
and if a fetus inside her body can
survive
excuse me can't survive right in this
country you can only do that like you're
just gonna whatever you're trying to get
out of me i don't know what you're
looking for but you're not gonna get it
because i'm telling you exactly what my
position is you know your position is
you're scared to actually say because
the left will come at you
no
bro bro how many times a woman has a
right to choose whatever she's not
talking about a woman but you refuse to
say it because this is this is the issue
but that's what that's what abortion is
if the baby is at the point of birth
kathy tran said it could be killed in
the situation where the woman's life or
there is something how do they get the
baby out how do they get the baby out
the woman
what do you mean having a baby
a woman is nine months pregnant sure at
the point of birth
she is dilating
kathy tran said yes you can end the life
of the baby as per the cdc's definitions
is that what she said yes if that's what
she said okay then there must be a
reason that it's done it's not just
babies coming out and she goes i don't
want it what's the reason
okay so the baby has the
baby the baby has to be removed from the
woman right
the baby has to be removed from the
woman the pregnancy is bad the baby has
to be here are you talking like a
miscarriage no no i'm saying when kathy
tran said
at the point of birth i'm sorry it was a
judge i believe a judge who said a woman
is dying at the point of birth could you
perform an abortion said there are no
restrictions none no limitations it was
then
stated to ralph northam even to the
point of birth abortion as the cdc
defines it is
a no-live birth removal of the pregnancy
how do they get the baby out of the
woman
money
the same way that you would you
what are you asking like she gives birth
but but an abortion ends the life of the
baby according to the cdc sure so if
they would legalize abortion up to the
point of birth that means ending
a termination of a pregnancy that
results in no live birth would mean they
need to take action to end the life of
the baby as it's coming out
so if you're saying there needs to be a
reason my question is okay
how do you propose they get a fully
developed baby at nine months out of a
womb when it needs to be removed uh
it depends on what the doctor decides is
right c-section or birth no abortion
ends the life of the baby sure so how do
they remove the baby and end its life at
the same time at nine months
that doesn't happen there's no abortions
happening once the baby is out of the
body the law they proposed would
legalize that no it wouldn't because
that would be homicide because that is
now a person you're starting to get it
that's a person you're starting to get
it at birth when the baby is out and
becomes a baby it is a person and that
would be considered homicide not an
abortion and homicide is illegal
crazy law that it just magically it's a
person instantly now it has legal
protections i mean that's exactly what
the law says it's a really bad law i
mean that's what the law is
let me just try and see if i can pull it
up the baby gets a name then the baby
gets a birth certificate oh the baby is
already legal in some cases
i mean a lot of
social security number baby uh
those things are what make you a human
in this country under the laws what
makes you a person there's a difference
between being a human and a person
disagree i think humans are persons
that's a false acknowledges strict
people of their rights every time that
distinction is made that these humans
are not persons worthy of rights and
protections it is always an argument to
strip them of the rights and do horrific
things and and i pointed out too it's
never it's never that's always been the
losing side always with the losing side
every every every argument throughout
history that some people aren't legally
people has always failed
so uh tran acknowledges her bill which
was killed in a 5-3 vote would allow a
woman to receive an abortion even up to
the point when she is about to give
birth the virginia house gop tweeted the
legislation would provide abortions up
to just seconds before the precious
child takes their first breath
right that means before the baby is born
but at the point of birth seconds before
you think there's a distinction if the
yes there's distinction one is a baby is
born and the other one it's not and
there has to be a medical concern for
either the mother or the fetus
no there should be a medical concern and
i've told you i mentioned this early on
the show there have been entire
petitions signed by doctors saying that
this idea of a medically necessitated
abortion is a myth you've also
repeatedly claimed that late term
abortions don't happen it's only because
there's some extreme reason why they
need to but i say they don't said they
don't happen but i quoted the guttmacher
institute the most pro-choice abortion
related think take in this country their
own numbers and according to them late
term abortions only happen because there
is some
fetal anomaly
one to two percent of the times one
third of the time it's because the woman
says she mis she underestimated how far
along she was 25 percent of the time
they said they tried to arrange an
earlier abortion couldn't 14 said they
were afraid at that point to tell their
parents or partner the rest cited
something along the lines of taking
their time to decide or a change in
their relationship status i'm gonna i'm
gonna throw but that's just so your
point is completely wrong but you've
said this repeatedly that doesn't happen
and it's somewhere with a public
platform when you're speaking about a
life and death issue where infants are
being slaughtered you have a
responsibility to know that it does in
fact happen and stop saying that
stop saying but i don't stop saying it
doesn't happen you said multiple times
it doesn't happen what's the language so
we can show them yeah i can pull up it's
a 1988 guttmacher institute so 1988
well because they don't survey this
anymore because guess what they didn't
get the results that they wanted
i'm just gonna i'm gonna do this i'm
gonna be a little bit uh condescending
and i'm gonna uh point out
where
why it's so difficult to do these shows
sheamus chose data at least from 1988 it
happened
uh we have edge cases that are clearly
citable we have the legal definition of
abortion
we have a clear moral uh difference
but i'll give you an example of where i
think the problem lies and i'm going to
throw it back to explain
the thanos moment with sam cedar
sam doesn't know what deontology or
utilitarianism is and when i was having
a conversation with him and i referenced
deontological thinking versus
utilitarianism he said i don't
understand what that is
how do you explain to someone who
doesn't understand these concepts what
they are how would you propose i i
explain deontology or utilitarianism i
don't know i don't know what if i use
something that is common to most people
like a movie i mean if you want to do
that maybe if i'm dealing with someone
who doesn't know philosophy they're not
i'm not saying that this is the thing i
understand on your show and you like to
have discussion but i don't i don't deal
in the philosophical i just don't i just
don't i deal with actual policy and
what's actually going on and what
happens to people in real life
what do you think i mean by
philosophical it's nice to just opining
about hypotheticals you do that all the
time that's not what i'm talking about
okay then what well this is another
another really great point sure i think
that you and sam lack the perspicacity
to understand the context of the
arguments and the substance of them so
in the context of sam cedar i made a
reference to
deontology
that a moral act against a single
individual cannot be an immoral act
against a single individual shall not be
taken versus utilitarianism which is
more the argument that the needs of the
money outweigh the needs of the few
which is also a pop culture reference
the idea being that we tend to see
villainous people as those who are
willing to sacrifice people for the sake
of other people we tend to see heroes as
those who are willing to save the
individual
sam didn't know what those words meant
sure but they're hugely important to our
policy in this country the trolley
problem as it were
is a question about whether you're
willing to kill a person
to save five people these are questions
of deontology versus utilitarianism sam
doesn't know those words and i'm not
saying it to be mean to him it's not i'm
not not everybody knows philosophy but
if i'm trying to convey ideas
the only thing i can do is try to find
common ground between us
big movie just came out avengers
so if you don't understand deontology
utilitarianism which is the academic
approach i can try the pop culture
approach me i love pop culture
references
instead of oh no you do yeah instead of
actually addressing the substance of the
issue instead sam and many others just
mocked the idea that i had to dumb down
the concepts for him because he didn't
get it you see this is a problem if i
approach in good faith sam with a
question about philosophy that he cannot
understand because he doesn't know these
terms so i try to find common ground and
he mocks me for it what is my incentive
to even try
what does that have to do with it sounds
like an issue you should take up with
sam
i mean i'm i'm here are you are you
trying to say that i was doing that on
this show i think i was being very
upfront and honest with you guys i've
given you guys my full-blown opinions
and everything i i agree i appreciate
you coming i just my point is
i don't know how many times sheamus and
i who completely disagree on the issue
of abortion can try to explain to you
legal terms definitions the body of a
baby versus the body of the mother you
can't understand it how do i have a
conversation with you if you don't
understand what we're saying no i do
understand what you're saying i'm i'm i
don't like i'm reiterating to you what
my position is and you just don't want
to accept that as my position like i'm
telling you in the most plainest words
like when we say
a baby has its own body you say it's the
mother's body and we're like we're not
talking about the mother's body you say
but it's the mother's body i'm like i
don't know how many times we got to say
it's the baby's body well it's if it's
if it's inside of her body as a fetus
then it's whatever you're discussing
whatever you want to try to uh go about
from that perspective or direction the
ultimate decision comes from uh comes to
the mother
i want to make i want to make one more i
just want to make one more statistical
point because you didn't like that study
was from 88 i found something newer a
2013 study published by the macro
institute states that data suggests that
women most women seeking later term
abortions are not doing so for reasons
of fetal anomaly or life endangerment
how many how many women are having fetal
abortion i'm sorry uh
late term abortions period though it
does it's it's an evil horrific what
year was that that's 2013. oh 2013. yeah
i mean i do kind of feel like if sheamus
has made two references and you haven't
made any then you're in the weaker
position okay like so
see my attitude tends to be like
if if someone's like like to me me to me
this isn't like a thing where i'm trying
to score points or win i'm giving you
guys what my position is no i respect
look i'm to be i'm not trying to score
points either most of the show i haven't
talked because i didn't want this to be
like we're double teaming you there were
a few times i wanted to jump in and yeah
but but with a couple you should have a
couple statistical points
i'd be happy to do it again at some
point but there was just a couple
statistical points that i really did
feel a need to correct this is a really
great example of
why do people call me right wing let's
let's let's i think i don't know if
we're going to get to the members only
guys we think we're just doing it right
now this is it we're giving it away
we're free what makes me right-wing
well you you say you advocate for these
positions but earlier i got you to say
that you know if your position um if the
uh you know you actually said that you
preferred uh if to stand next to me or
the ending of roe v wade you prefer the
ending of roe v wade no i didn't say roe
v wade i mean you said banning of
abortion yeah so you stand with the
banning of abortion what
you tell my reasoning you
you're in favor of terminating babies
lives at nine months but you don't you
don't seem to care about the life of the
mother i do no but you don't if you say
if you said you'd rather ban abortions
than well babies in my position then you
say the mother's life is worse less than
the the grown the growing human's life
is worth less than an unborn fetus no no
but that is the position then they could
deliver the baby
they could deliver what if they can make
it what if they cannot then i said the
provision should be added that all
efforts must be made to preserve them
but they didn't add to them well we're
talking about we're not talking about
positions i said in your context if the
issue was you telling me a baby could be
killed at the point of birth or banning
abortion i would choose banning abortion
i didn't say i wanted to bad abortion
i'm saying your position is so extreme
you've pushed me to the other side if
that's my only option okay but we're now
using that hypothetical that's what
we're talking about now you don't like
hypotheticals i don't like hypothetical
but you love philosophical discussion so
let's do it philosophical hypothetical
different things okay well let's do the
philosophical then you said before that
um
you would rather stand with people who
want to ban all abortion than kill
babies and stand with my position sure
fine so that means then that as a result
women who would die if they don't have
an abortion would die no that is the
result of that that is the result i
don't i see this this is the point i was
making before about your
your inability
to understand the argument but
okay i'm playing by your rules now so a
woman is nine months pregnant
the the pregnancy needs to end now what
should they do no but we're not talking
about these specifics anymore though
when i talk your position was
stand with me
who according to you
has this position and then
number oh you're like talking to a brick
wall how's was talking a brick wall i'm
going by your own position already said
if my choices are between
someone saying
end the life of a baby at nine months
or no abortion at all i would choose no
abortion yes
that is
if there were two extremes i would opt
for the one that for the most part does
not kill the baby and in that
now hold on okay
abortion according to the cdc
terminates the life of the baby
if a woman's health is at risk because
of a pregnancy
you do not need to kill the baby to save
the woman right and they don't do that
if they can't if they if they can save
and give the birth to the child that's
what they do and that's why my position
was
they should just add a provision saying
that to the bill otherwise
it would allow for babies to be killed
and that's one of the issues i have with
it okay that's that's a little bit
different than what we're discussing
before we have to go back probably and
listen to it but we're not going to do
that now i understand we're just going
to keep going in circles
but your last statement is not true that
they don't do that they do perform
abortions at that stage but that's how i
mean he's cited too
i've cited actually three different
sources of statistics on this right but
it's not just like maintaining your
position but it's not just like oh i'm
feeling depressed there must be
something that is actually i know that's
happened just a woman according to
according to a partial birth i cited
partial abortionist james mcmahon said
that is the number one reason cited
depression the the primary reason given
by those requesting the procedure is
depression but there's a difference
between someone who's debilitating
depression and then someone who's just
i'm sure what you're thinking like oh
no i'm not thinking that i think
debilitating depression is a horrible
thing i don't think it necessitates
killing an unborn child i mean i would
have to leave that up to the woman and
the doctor well i wouldn't because i
think it's wrong to kill people and i
don't just leave that up to whoever's
doing it
the the uh traditional like position
on abortion among democrat voters has
been there's got to be some restrictions
right and there are your position is
like we should get rid of them no that's
not my position i think what we have
right now works
i mean you you do yeah i mean states are
banning abortion roe v wade and he's
killed
yeah and like several states have like
oklahoma outright banned it not yet no
no they did not yet you can't no no oh
not until the decision comes down no no
no no no didn't oklahoma did they pass
that bill already i thought they did we
might double check yeah where they it
can't go into effect though until
the supreme court decision i mean
california's got uh
they don't enforce immigration laws like
it doesn't matter what the [ __ ] but what
is that what are you talking about we're
talking about specifically in oklahoma
okay dude
why did you bring up immigration just
now you made a point about how the
federal government made a restriction i
said there's examples of restrictions
don't they have no impact
you cannot
make abortion illegal outright in this
country right now roe v wade
kcv uh planned parenthood
i know what this is you're trying to
stay on the show
i hope you guys are having a good time
really i mean no no i've given you a
hard time giving you a hard time no i i
appreciate it i love this stuff yeah no
it's been an interesting discussion
and it's good you know you usually don't
have people on who who we usually don't
have left-wing people on yeah so and
it's not it's not that we don't invite
them they usually don't come but it's
you know brave of you to come here you
should have sam cedar on
no sam sam
yeah
so he rescinded when i uh invited sam on
the show he publicly accepted and
privately told me no well i don't know i
know the whole situation i mean
published all the dna i mean you need to
punish them that dude is a bad faith
actor who
he the scam on stephen crowder for
internet points
oh yeah great let's like not have a real
conversation and just well that's what
sam wanted to have
sam wanted to actually discuss with
crowder crowder was going to talk to
ethan klein right and sam intruded upon
the conversation even invited him but
and stephen didn't know well
so this is why
like it's for one of the reasons we
don't do uh digital conversations
because they're bad they're always bad
faith well i got a surprise for you open
that door no you wouldn't be able to get
in the house with the security we have
now especially
uh maybe it was kansas that out right it
was it kansas
oh there's
there was something that actually we
brought the same thing and i have
something i meant to ask you actually um
you you did a video um it's actually
been on my mind for a little bit now you
did a video when that happened
and you said something um the about the
the sam cedar crowder debate or that
didn't happen
uh where ethan kline invited sam
and uh there was something you said
where i i don't have it verbatim but it
was something like uh
if you're if you're
if your viewers are wrestling fans uh
they might remember when um stone cold
steve austin
ruined vince to command's big moment
with mike tyson
and vince mcmahon started yelling you
ruined it austin you ruined it you would
like a moment like that where you were
screaming at like sam and ethan that
they they ruined it they ruined it i
don't know anything about wrestling okay
but you you had me thinking of somebody
else no no i'm that was my that was my
addiction oh that was my anecdote you
you oh yeah you said something you said
something like you but what did they
ruin i don't know what they ruined
steven crowder wanted to have a real
conversation with ethan klein and sam
put on his clown nose and shut it down
but ethan klein never wanted to no no
he's never lie
yeah sure i mean come on dude i mean you
up and do a pull up but do you think
this into a politics look i i you know
it's it's it's i i know what the end
result of shows was like who was who was
the who was the um who was the the
networks that you mentioned that
blacklist sound
oh i'm not going to talk about that
publicly on aaron i think i know who it
is but there's there's a handful yeah
sam's blacklisted from yeah from a few
places be surprised because he's a bad
actor so like i've
i'm i'm i have spoken with people and
i've asked them and they have said
this is why we won't engage with him
well i'm sure they think he's a bad
actor i mean he he'll ask the stephen
crowder thing was like that's the kind
of thing that gets you removed from
bookings
bookings with who
networks
networks like who so
i know you can't mention okay you're
trying to look right right now i'm not
trying to actually not try it was a
legit interest um in terms of what you
were talking about let's say big shows
well-funded shows typical mainstream
like on the mainstream shows mainstream
shows not like on tv
mainstream shows across the board
without me getting anybody in trouble
because right he's dancing too close but
uh bro that that stunt with uh with
ethan was like
i can't believe he pulled that off i
can't believe he did that and that's
what you're wearing
it's
i mean i mean for sure in his space
uh he's got his own youtube channel he's
insulated in that regard but like
you blacklist yourself when you tell
people
look we can have a conversation we have
an argument we can get heated we even
had people smack the microphone and rage
i didn't even do that not even you and
we've invited that guy back we're like
bro we get it things get heated you're
always welcome back on because that's
not but sam stunt was like not just for
me but a bunch of other people like
that's not a guy you have on your show
because i was just interested in that
really just out of my curiosity
truthfully just wanted to know what you
meant by it so uh there are a lot of
channels that focus on inter
interpersonal intercommentary drama we
do a little bit
we we mostly try to avoid it unless it's
overwhelming like joe rogan controls the
news cycle sometimes so we'll talk about
them but i don't i don't address every
single thing every time someone talks
about anything like that uh when you do
too much and i always give this advice
to people who are starting channels
avoid intercommentary drama
like if if you're if you've got 100k
subs and there's another personality was
on the left or the right they got 100k
subs
ignore them
because if you start doing these
conversations where it's like did you
hear what so-and-so said about me did
you hear what so-and-so did which is
what a lot of people do
it what happens at higher higher
industry levels
they they basically say we don't we
don't we don't need that so that's like
advertisers don't like that that's
interesting because like you got to sort
of respect them that sam cedar wouldn't
censor himself in that way what do you
mean i mean you said that if you have
one channel that's like 100k another
channel 100k and you're you're one of
those channels you should not you know
go after yourself yourself like if you
if that was sam cedar being himself for
sure for sure if if sam and i'm not
saying he hasn't doesn't have the right
to choose us i'm saying the result of it
has been blacklisting so there's been so
you're saying is to get on those other
channels there's been a lot of people
who self-censor themselves
no
so uh there are a lot of people who do
this i'm saying if you're looking for a
career
if you want uh to reach a higher level
you want personally i think sam's at a
point where he knows exactly where his
career is and i think he's for sure he's
got a million subs i mean he's probably
super rich no he's i mean i think you
know i think when i mean he knows where
his career is i don't think i'm i'm not
saying like he's in some great position
what i'm actually saying is uh he knows
that he has a point that he is hit and
that's where he's going to go based on
his own content because he doesn't pull
any punches he'll do whatever that he
feels like he wants to do so he doesn't
um you know he doesn't self-censor
himself just not to go after someone in
terms of being worried we're not talking
about self-censorship well this sort of
self-censorship in a way if you don't
want to go after someone specifically
because you're worried about not getting
booked on your show i agree with that
and that's not what i'm talking about so
what i'm saying is
if your goal is to have a like you want
to talk about the news you want to talk
about concepts ideas and events you got
to avoid the interpersonal drama well a
lot of what sam goes after when it comes
to interpersonal drama it's not really
like inter it's not personal in a sense
of like oh he was mean to me like he
commonly he regularly does videos on you
know jimmy dore on dave rubin because he
disagrees vehemently with what they what
they put out
every one of those videos you could look
up and sure he mocks them and they have
fun with it that's sort of like the
point of the show it's sort of like an
old school like leftist version of
howard stern or something i guess you
can say but um yeah i suppose they mock
they mock these guys but they always go
after like they're not like making fun
of how dave rubin uh
uh quaffed his hair or whatever the you
know he's not they're making fun of uh
uh jimmy jordan's dresses or whatever
well we're not the young turks no i know
um i'm just i'm dragging them and
everything sam goes after them and
always makes it about the substance of
what they say and their policy um when
he intruded on crowd or he didn't just
do it to go like ah surprise he wanted
to have a legit discussion about
uh coven 19 policy um he was supposed to
have a this is why
people like crowder won't have
conversations with them well he wouldn't
have a conversation before sam did that
and you and this is exactly why but sam
didn't do that before no no no it's it's
it's an issue of tendencies personality
and the things he's done
like so that stunt
i know
resulted in like
big shows being like right yeah guy man
because like look so banned from the
networks that's pretty well i don't know
i'm not going to say every i i can't
speak foreign
[Laughter]
what what people with bigger shows are
looking for is prestige
and relatability and substance so you
want to be authoritative not elitist
you want to create something of value
that people that can help people in
their daily lives
when you see a stunt like what
sam did
the the presentation is that this guy
doesn't address issues that people
relate to
the the stunt with stephen crowder was a
tribalist stunt which plays well to
culture warriors which are a very small
portion of the marketplace
if you're trying to do a show that
speaks to regular americans is either
influencing policy sharing your ideas or
just you know addressing issues that
more people care about
doing stunts
and interpersonal drama
diminishes that and makes people not
want to engage which makes the people
out of their shows say
look
what we want to do here at tim cast irl
is share ideas even yours with as many
people as possible sure we can't
accomplish that with someone like sam
cedar so we don't have him on the show
well i wouldn't be able to accomplish
that with him if you invited
when i tweeted come on the show he
publicly says i'll do it then privately
says no i won't well that was because
that was because he played us to get
clicked and then went look at me
because this is what he does for
attention he is a bad faith actor
who when i said we'll fly you out and
cover all the costs he said how does
this day work i said you got it i'll dm
you for details and then he privately
says i ain't doing it hassan did the
same thing bro well i'm glad you invited
me and i came on and i know you know and
i would you know and uh i think it was a
good discussion i do and i think we've
run way too long i think i gotta send it
matt it really was great i really do
appreciate you coming you are welcome
back any time well thank you we'll have
you on with other people um if you have
any ideas for anyone you want to talk to
we we're all
i'd love to have you know debate someone
you know who's got a stronger you know
uh political ideology or something we
did charlie kirk and vosh you know for
the most part had them have their
conversation i saw the poster that's
pretty cool yeah we made that poster for
him and uh i'll tell you this man in all
honesty
we invite people on the left all the
time they won't do it oh well i'll do it
anytime we'll have you on again dude i
really appreciate it for everybody who
watched
look we got crazy man i'm sorry about
the super chats um we didn't even really
get to the the the shooting of the
weekend
that's that's really bad i apologize for
that too um
but this is what usually happens and
then everyone's like
half people are saying it's time it's
done half the people are saying no keep
going and i'm just like it's 11 30.
we're an hour and a half over we're not
going to get a member segment and
basically consider the member segment
free uh support us at timcast.com we're
gonna have more shows like this more
more questions more debates and we'll
we'll try and do better and better each
time we do it and uh bring a friend
we'll we'll you know we'll have you come
on with somebody else bring a friend
yeah yeah find somebody yeah i think
that would actually be good well no i i
i i said can i bring sam yeah
i think that's a good idea because like
there were a lot of parts of the
discussion i wanted to jump into i
jumped into a couple of them because i
really felt a need but for the most part
it was like i didn't i really didn't
want this to become two on one no i
think so i think it would be great i
think it would be great if you like
brought another person to the backyard
and that's what if we could be really
loud and then this could go until four
in the morning and we can
i mean i could i sometimes my own
streams i go on for hours and hours what
are we doing now yeah i mean sometimes
you're going deep into the night it's
like talking about one in the morning
two in the morning sometimes um you know
if if you were open to it i could
certainly promise you on my own that you
know samson would behave with me here if
it's it's not about behavior it's about
i think his stick is tribal rage
well that's interesting yep yeah that's
interesting yeah like we'll invite you
on the show yeah and we'll have a
conversation i think you know he just
shocked jocks
so like this the stephen crowder thing
was a stunt the thing he pulled with me
was a stunt his goal is to like woo to
his base my goal is to like bring you on
in front of my base and say like here's
a dude who's got some ideas let's hear
him no we'll argue about him sure i
think sam is just like the thanos thing
is a really great example of like
if a guy doesn't understand philosophy
and i try to relate to him so he mocks
me for it that's not good faith like
making an argument about me trying to
relate to you is bad things right
i'm not going to entertain that you
wouldn't just hit me i you know
the original uh i know you want to end
this show i'm sorry but it just hit me
right now um you know i thought that's
not i thought you said do you want to
just hit me
that's what i i was like right here
buddy i thought you were like joking i
didn't know
you went just hit me right now you know
when when you reached out to me and we
we uh reconnected to make this happen it
was over like the
the libs of tick tock stuff right right
and you brought that we didn't get to
talk about that because i actually um
since we last discussed this i actually
went ahead
and i did the work i made foil requests
uh freedom of information requests
and um i have uh all the information in
terms of where she has lived like her
home address and i can confirm
that the information that she has given
to public record which is where all that
information you see online would come
from
she has never lived at that address that
was on that real estate license
according to who according to who
according to new york state
so i have from new york state that she
did i also have personal sources who've
confirmed it you should show me because
i can't i can't challenge i'm on the
show yeah i have i have uh i have i have
voter records i have um uh donation
records in terms of a political campaign
she donated to i have the in case you're
wondering oh okay that maybe just shows
uh you know doesn't prove it without a
shadow of a doubt did teresa wren's
publish an address they tell her she
published a address in address yes she
published a business address for that
real estate company and where did libs
of tick tock work not there
she literally at that time she was not
living there no she did not i mean she
was not working there for that company
she was not working there at the time
that article was published now so you're
saying taylor runs did publish an
address in the link that was originally
posted that's that's without a doubt
but we agree she doctor
well she didn't live there or well she
didn't it's published
she actually didn't even work there he's
publishing an address dachshund is
publishing an address boxing not no not
if it's not connected to
[Music]
did you hear it from you could just you
don't expose did you hear it from the
one person who would be able to probably
give you the outright answer libs of
tick tock i will not confirm or deny the
identity of the source who gave me well
i haven't until the after show so pay if
you want to see it i mean i also have uh
the the uh the uh details for every
person who has lived there over the past
10 12 years so do we yes good and i also
have the uh the uh mortgage on the
building and i have the deed to the
building none of which she's connected
to why did they remove the address where
they move the address because they
decided that it wasn't relevant to the
story because she didn't why did they
deny posting the address i don't know
why they did that i don't know i can't
tell you they posted that address where
she was listed as working where she was
listed at as living according to public
records but she's not living where i
have sources who say she did
and uh there you go so
bro if you want to argue the semantics
on doc could you you could offline i
would love if you showed me the
information you have like once we end
the show i would love for you to show
that to me i will pull it up and i could
show actually brought the you know i
could show you
let's wrap things up and show you the
way i just i just this happens all the
time or like before a show i'll assume
we're going to talk about some things
and do some research and then like this
conversation goes in so many different
directions basically every episode right
but we'll we'd love to chat with you
yeah everybody smash the like button uh
there's your free extra hour and a half
yeah i'm sorry with super chats and they
got nuked and then we just argued too
much so you're welcome tim cast viewers
it was all on me absolutely and um but
we'll just consider the members only
having been free for this one around and
uh if you like the show and you want to
help support us go to timcast.com sign
up support our journalists support our
infrastructure support our work and you
can follow the show at timcast irl you
can follow me at tim cast matt you want
to shout anything out yeah sure follow
me on twitter mattbinder and uh you know
all my details are on there we didn't
even talk about cryptocurrency oh my god
greatest thing ever ah i disagree but um
go to mattbinder check me out there uh
and i do a youtube show uh twice a week
i actually take calls which means you
can call into my show either there's no
like screener i literally open up skype
i give you my skype username i take the
calls as they come in and i have a
discussion with literally anybody and
everybody leftist conservative right
winger anyone who calls in open for
discussion even pro bitcoin people uh
and uh you know uh call in uh check it
out i'm at binder all the details will
be there i got a ringer
it's unfair to you but i have to do it
binder is wrong on all counts the juan
carlos vera settlement was for an
invasion of privacy lawsuit and had
nothing to do with allegedly deceptive
edits in any way even the new york times
owned public editor revisited the acorn
tapes and found that quote the record
does not support o'keeffe's detractors
about acorn according to acorn's own
lawyer quote they said what they said
there is no way to make this look good
second vendor's claim that minnesota
allows ballot harvesting is similarly
wrong the new york times made a similar
claim we sued them they filed a md mtd
we won then the new york times was
forced in their answer to admit the law
banning ballot harvesting was always in
place and their article was wrong binder
would do well to retract that statement
as has the times as the time is
effectively done okay we have little
time so i will say that if everything
there is true i will retract those
statements sure and i'll also say that
that um that researcher i was reading it
more after while we were after we got
past that area of the conversation so i
should say this now for sure um
if that
that researcher that you had about the
youtube study
what i read was actually him defending
whether q anon content should be allowed
on social media so i retract and
apologize for uh misstating exactly what
that piece was all about
yeah well i mean no really it takes a
big man to apologize and also it's tough
coming on a show where people have
adversarial views to yours so we really
do appreciate you coming out here and
you didn't have a computer yeah and you
don't have to i just want to let people
know yeah he did not have a computer did
people who watch this show who weren't
told that their guests the guests had
like if you didn't know the guests had a
computer due to like tim or sheamus or
lydia saying something did have you ever
viewed a computer at this desk i've
never seen one on screen you guys frame
it out
i gotta be honest everyone brings one
basically i've i don't know
i guess i shouldn't say every single
person most but it has noticed it on the
screen i always said maybe i always
assume that
because here's one thing this is a giant
table i've never noticed that before i
thought you all had your own desks and
maybe if i did see a screen i thought
there was just a monitor in front of
them we have a wide shot we never use it
yeah yeah this is just one big table
we're all sitting at i really thought we
watched separate desks set up and again
i'm sorry for doing this i know you guys
are tired no no
we again we really appreciate being here
next time
no honestly honestly it's not it's it's
not easy um and so i just want to shout
out freedom students i also want to
shout out my special announcement i know
the viewership is doing at this point
but i did promise you guys i would tell
you we are going to be launching the
website uh we're going to have that
launched on may 30th and we are going to
have a members section we're calling it
freedom tunes plus it's going to be plus
size sheamus and you are going to get an
extra cartoon each week you're also
going to get behind the scenes footage
it's going to be five bucks a month so
if you want to go over to
freedomtunes.com t-o-o-n-s put in your
email into our mailing list when the
website's launched you'll get all of it
i love you all in the meantime subscribe
to the channel you're getting new videos
this week i love you all i hate to do
this you just reminded me i didn't check
out my i'm on your youtube show how do
you check out my youtube channel
youtube.combinder subscribe even if you
hate me and disagree with me vehemently
please subscribe watch and call in i
really want to talk with you good faith
discussion for sure please
youtube.combinder let me see if this
works i think yep there you go there's a
wide shot it's a huge table isn't it
that's the one huge tape
there's matt uh
you'll see it appear up there in a
second yeah there's a delay for about a
minute yeah anyway i'm here in the
corner i was here this whole time
believe it or not thank you very much
for coming matt i hope you all
appreciated our uh wild and crazy extra
super long and i hope you enjoyed this
free bonus episode we swore a lot less
than we usually do but i feel like we
got
most of our points in [ __ ] um
you guys can follow me on
twitterminds.com at sarah patchoulits we
will see you all tomorrow uh same time
and you can go to chicken city live and
watch chickens
and uh we'll see you tomorrow 8pm as per
usual we have uh
i'm not going to say with the guys we
usually don't but thanks for going out
we'll see y'all next time
you